THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
FIRST I JUST LIKE -- TO THANK
YOU AGAIN OUR OUR COLLECTIVE.
BUDGET COMMITTEE STAFFS FOR ALL
THEIR WORK THIS YEAR I I KNOW
BOTH ON THE MAJORITY AND THE
MINORITY SIDE.
HAVE PUT IN A HUGE AMOUNT OF
EFFORT AGAIN TO REALLY GET US TO
THIS POINT -- I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE WHO I KNOW HAVE
HAD TO SIT THROUGH HOURS AND
HOURS AND NUMEROUS.
NUMEROUS OUR HEARINGS OF
TESTIMONY AND REALLY APPRECIATE
ALL THE VERY HARD WORK -- THIS
YEAR IS WE HAVE A NEW GOVERNOR
THE GOVERNOR UNVEILED HIS NEW
BUDGET VERY EARLY ON IN JANUARY
OF THIS VERY EXCITING.
BECAUSE MUCH OF WHAT WAS
DETAILED IN THE BUDGET I REALLY
DID NOT CHANGE IN MAY.
AND MANY OF THOSE PROPOSALS
REFLECTED MUCH OF WHAT WE AS AN
ASSEMBLY HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING
FOR WHETHER IT WAS.
HEALTH CARE FOR MORE
CALIFORNIANS OR INCREASING THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT OR
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE -- MORE
INVESTMENT IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION THOSE ARE ALL ISSUES
THAT WE'RE VERY PROUD TO HAVE
BEEN CHAMPING OF THE LAST FEW
YEARS.
AND IN PARTICULAR WERE VERY
HAPPY TO SEE THAT WE HAD AN
INCOMING GOVERNOR WHO -- WAS
LISTENING AND ABSORBING WELL
WHAT LEGISLATIVE POWERS HAVE
BEEN INCORPORATED THEM IN HIS
JANUARY BUDGET SO THAT WAS A A
GREAT -- A GREAT DEPARTURE I
THINK FROM WHAT -- GOVERNOR
BROWN HAD DONE IN THE PAST AND
WE WERE VERY PLEASED TO SEE IT.
I IN PARTICULAR THAT YOU KNOW
OUR ASSEMBLY -- BUDGET HAD A
COUPLE.
MAJOR AREAS WE WE WANTED TO
FOCUS ON RESTORING MANY OF THE
BUDGET CUTS ESPECIALLY IN THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AREAS
WHICH WERE DONE DURING THE
RECESSION UNFORTUNATELY -- THOSE
PROGRAMS WERE.
THE THE LAST ONES TO SEE
RESTORATION SO WE WERE HAPPY
THIS HAVE SOME PRIORITIZATION OF
THOSE -- PROGRAMS INCLUDED IN
OUR VERSION OF THE BUDGET -- WE
ALSO PRIORITIZE EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION AS YOU KNOW OUR
SPEAKER THECONVENE A BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION.
THE STUDY THE ISSUE FOR OVER
YOUR CAME WITH NUMEROUS
RECOMMENDATIONS -- WE DECIDED TO
MAKE SURE THAT EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION INVESTING IN CHILDREN
EARLY ON WAS ALSO A MAJOR
PRIORITY.
WE HEARD FROM -- Q. THROUGH
TWELVE SCHOOLS THAT THIS IS --
THERE AT THAT WE DID NOT INVEST
ENOUGH IN.
THEM -- WE A PARTICULAR FOCUS TO
OUR OUR FUNDING IN INCREASING
AND HAVING MORE MONEY FOR FOR K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS BUT ALSO
IN PARTICULAR -- MORE MONEY FOR
CAL STARS -- WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S BEEN NOT MORE PRESSURE
ON DISTRICTS TO FIND MONEY INTO
CAL STARS AND SO WE WANT.
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
NOT ONLY WILL RE INCREASING
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING BUT THAT WE
ALSO WERE INCREASING OUR CAL
STARS FUNDING -- WITH THAT LET
ME JUST TURN IT OVER TO EACH OF
OUR SUB CHURCH WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH.
VERY BRIEFLY WHAT HAD OCCURRED
IN THEIR SUB COMMITTEES AND THEN
WHEN I LIKE TO ASK IS -- FOR
FINANCE AND ELLIE -- TO RESPOND
AND THEN WE CAN OPEN UP TO THAT
TO MEMBERS AFTER THAT SOMEONE IS
TRYING TO TALK TO ARAMBULA.
IN AND OF COURSE DOCTOR AT THE
MISS RATES COME OUT IN.
IF FIVE MAY I MAY HAVE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RADIUS BEGIN.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
SPEAKER DR RAVELO FOR TRUSTING
ME WITH THE RAPID RESPONSIBILITY
OF TEMPORARILY CHAIRING SUB.
ONE SUCH AN IMPORTANT
SUBCOMMITTEE GOVERNING OUR
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES SAFETY
NET.
OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF MONTHS
I'VE DEVELOPED A PROFOUND
RESPECT AND APPRECIATION. FOR
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE IT'S MEMBERS
THE SUB ONE COMMUNITY OF
PASSIONATE CAM IS COMMITTED
STAKEHOLDERS AND ADVOCATES AND
MOST OF ALL FOR THE MILLIONS OF
VULNERABLE STRUGGLING
CALIFORNIANS SERVED BY THE
MYRIAD OF PROGRAMS OVERSEEN BY
THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
EVEN IN STRONG ECONOMIC TIMES
THE WORK OF SUB ONE IS
CHALLENGING EMOTIONAL AND
AFFECTS THE QUALITY OF LIFE OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS. TO BEGIN.
GIVEN THAT THIS IS IN FACT A
STRONG ECONOMIC TIME THAT WE ARE
IN TODAY AND THE FACT THAT THE
GREAT RECESSION IS BECOMING A
DISTANT MEMORY.
WE FEEL THAT RESTORING
RECESSIONARY CUTS IS LONG
OVERDUE.
THEREFORE SOMEONE APPROVED OF
RESTORING AN ARRAY OF OPTIONAL
MEDI CAL BENEFITS INCLUDING
OPTICAL PODIATRY SPEECH THERAPY
AND OTHERS.
SOMEONE ALSO PROVED OF RESTORING
PROVIDER RATE CUTS THAT WERE
MADE PRIMARILY IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN AT THE HEIGHT OF THE
RECESSION.
INCLUDING.
COMMUNITY BASED ADULT SERVICES
NON EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TRANSPORTATION AND DURABLE
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT.
SOMEONE ALSO PROVED OF
ELIMINATING RATE FREEZES ADOPTED
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT FOR
FACILITIES THAT CARE FOR
EXTREMELY VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
NAMELY INTERMEDIATE CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED AS WELL
AS STANDALONE.
YEAH TRICKS SUBACUTE FOR
FACILITIES THAT CARE FOR OUR
MOST MEDICALLY COMPLEX AND
FRAGILE INFANTS AND CHILDREN.
WE'RE ALSO RESTORING SUBSTANTIAL
FUNDING TO OUR CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS.
A WOEFULLY UNDERFUNDED RESOURCE
IT HELPS TO KEEP OUR AGING LOVED
ONES AT HOME.
INSTEAD OF IN NURSING HOMES BY
SUPPORTING CARE GIVERS WHO ARE
OFTEN CARING FOR BOTH PARENTS
AND CHILDREN WHILE REMAINING IN
THE WORKFORCE.
BEYOND RESTORATION.
ARE SUB ONE PLAN INCLUDES IMPORT
EXPANSIONS TO HEALTH CARE
INCLUDING EXPANDING MEDICARE ALL
TO ALL TO ALL YOUNG ADULTS AS
WELL AS BY LIMIT AB THE
REDUCTION IN MEDI CAL
ELIGIBILITY.
THAT CURRENTLY OCCURS WHEN A
PERSON REACHES THEIR SIXTY FIFTH
BIRTHDAY.
THESE WERE KEY COMPONENTS OF THE
ASSEMBLY TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
SIGNATURE HEALTH CARE PACKAGE
FOR WHICH I WANT TO THANK
DOCTORS ARAMBULA.
AND WOOD FOR THEIR INSPIRING
LEADERSHIP.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK MISTER
RAMOS FOR ALWAYS REMINDING US OF
THE IMPORTANT NEEDS AND
CHALLENGES OF OUR TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES.
OVERALL ARE SUB ONE PLAN
PRIORITISES SUPPORTING OUR
SENIORS.
AS I JUST MENTIONED WE HAVE
APPROVED OF RAISING MEDI CAL
ELIGIBILITY AT AGE.
SIXTY FIVE TO THAT OF THE REST
OF THE MEDI CAL POPULATION.
WE HAVE ALSO PROVED A BACK FILL
IT APPROVED A BACK FILLING THE
LOSS OF FEDERAL FUNDS. FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY TRANSITIONS
PROGRAM AND FOR THE STATE TO
CONDUCT AN ACTUARIAL STUDY ON
ESTABLISHING A LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE PROGRAM.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK MISTER
PATTERSON FIRST PASSIONATE INPUT
INTO OUR DISCUSSION ON THE HOME
AND COMMUNITY BASED WAIVER
ISSUES WHICH AFFECT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE SENIORS.
ANOTHER SOMEONE PRIORITY THIS
YEAR ON THE HEALTH SIDE HAS BEEN
TO AGGRESSIVELY ADDRESS THE
STATE'S GROWING MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE CHALLENGES.
WE PROVIDED NEW RESOURCES FOR AN
IMPRESSIVE ARRAY OF SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS.
PROPOSED BY EITHER THE GOVERNOR.
THE LEGISLATURE OR STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING. ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION FOR HOUSING AND
OTHER INTEGRATED SERVICES FOR
THE HOMELESS MENTALLY ILL.
WE REDUCED MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES FUNDED MENTAL HEALTH
FIRST AID TRAINING FOR TEACHERS
AND MENTAL HEALTH WARM LINE
SERVICES.
WE SUPPORTED.
YOUR NAVIGATORS AND EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE
PROGRAMS WE SUPPORTED THE FRIDAY
NIGHT LIVE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS.
INCLUDED WE ALSO INCLUDE GRANTS
TO INCENTIVIZE FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH TO WORK IN MENTAL HEALTH
FIELDS.
ADDITIONALLY WE INCLUDED
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED
BILLION FOR TRAUMA SCREENINGS
AND MEDI CAL AND PROVIDER
TRAINING ON ADMINISTERING THE
SCREENS AND ISSUE THE DOCTOR
ARAMBULA HAS WORKED TIRELESSLY
TO BRING TO OUR COLLECTIVE
ATTENTION.
SOMEONE APPROVED OF A VERY
SIGNIFICANT PACKAGE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH INVESTMENTS.
THESE INCLUDE. FOR SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED DISEASES HIV AND
HEPATITIS C. PREVENTION AND
ALLOCATION OF TEN MILLION.
EACH.
WE ALSO INCLUDED THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF PARKINSON'S
DISEASE REGISTRY AND FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SICKLE CELL
DISEASE CENTERS FOR EXCELLENCE.
AND EIGHTY MILLION FOR
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE RESEARCH.
PUBLIC EDUCATION COMMUNITY CARE
LINKAGES AND OUR NEW CALIFORNIA
CARE COR.
WE WERE ABLE TO TAKE ACTION ON
MANY PROFOUNDLY IMPORTANT TO
NEEDED INVESTMENTS IN HUMAN
SERVICES.
BOTH TO RESTORE LONG SUSTAIN
BUDGET REDUCTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
IN EFFECT FOR FOR PASSED THE
GREAT RECESSION.
AND TO MAKE MEANINGFUL CHANGE
AND IMPROVEMENTS IN PROGRAMS
THAT SERVE OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS ARE SENIORS PERSONS
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
LOW WAGE WORKERS STRUGGLING TO
MAKE ENDS MEET AND CHILDREN.
THANKS TO THE LEADERSHIP OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM FRAZIER WE
ADOPTED REST RESTORATIONS FOR
RECESSION ERA CUTS IN THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AREA.
RESTORING SOCIAL RECREATION AND
CAMP.
HALF THE BILLING AND MOREOVER
CONTINUE CONTINUING THE
INVESTMENT IN DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY RATES AND THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE INTO THE LONG
TERM FORECAST.
WHICH WE HAD THAT WE ADOPTED
IMPORTANT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO REQUIRE THAT THE DISTANCE.
THE DD SYSTEM WIDE RATE REFORM
BE PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY. TEN TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET WHICH WOULD MEAN THAT WE
COULD GENUINELY PHASE THEM.
RATE REFORM STARTING JULY.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY ANOTHER
CHAMPION ON CORE ISSUES IS DR
JIM WOOD.
WITH YOUR SUPPORT AND
ENCOURAGEMENT WE'VE INCLUDED IN
OUR ASSEMBLY PLAN CRITICAL
FUNDING FOR THE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM WITH TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TOOK REQUIRE
QUARTERLY VISITS TO SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES.
AND RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES
FOR THE ELDERLY.
WE ALSO PROVIDED FUNDING FOR THE
MULTI PURPOSE SENIOR SERVICE
PROGRAM AND SENIOR NUTRITION
PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY PROVIDING ONGOING
SUPPORT TO THE CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE.
AND ASK CHAMPIONED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO.
WE MADE SIGNIFICANT STRIDES IN
CODIFYING LANGUAGE ALL VERY
MEANINGFUL TO THE CONSTITUENCY
OF CALIFORNIA WE CARE ABOUT.
SECURING THE ELIMINATION OF THE
7% REDUCTION RIGHT JUST AYE H.
SS IN STATUTE WITH SPECIAL FOCUS
ON EXPANDING PROGRAMS WHICH
ASSIST AYE HSS CONSIDERED CAN
SEWERS.
WE THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS
INVESTMENT IN CAL WORKS GRANTS
TOWARDS THE ENDING DEEP CHILD
POVERTY AND FOCUS THE RESOURCES
FIRST ON CASES WITH A CHILD IS
THE ONLY PERSON.
ACCOUNTED FOR IN THE BASIC GRANT.
THIS MAKES SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
TOWARD THE EVENTUAL ASSURANCE
WITHIN OUR REACH NOW.
THE WE CAN AND DEEP CHILD
POVERTY IN THE PROGRAM IN THE
NOT TOO DISTANT FUTURE.
ALSO THE CAL WORKS AREA IN THE
CAL WORKS AREA WE FINALLY
UPDATED THE EARNED INCOME
DISREGARD TO MAKE IT CORRELATE
TO THE INCREASES IN STATE
MINIMUM WAGE.
REWARDING WORK INSTEAD OF
PENALIZING AT THROUGH AN
OUTDATED PROGRAM RULE.
ADDITIONALLY THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S
PLAN GETS RID OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVELY BURDENSOME
ASSET TEST STREAMLINING
ENROLLMENT FOR FAMILIES.
WE ALSO CREATE THE FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE SYSTEM ANOTHER ISSUE
WHERE DOCTOR ARAMBULA HAS LED
THE WAY SUPPORTING THE STABILITY
A FOSTER FAMILY PLACEMENTS.
I KNOW OUR SHARED SO MUCH AND
THEY'RE SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
INVESTMENTS.
ON THE POLICY LEVEL ON THE HUMAN
LEVEL BUT I COULD MENTION BUT I
WILL STOP HERE.
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR MISTER
TING I WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS
AND THE PUBLIC. FOR YOUR KIND
ATTENTION IN SUB [inaudible]
ONE THANK YOU.
WELL WHAT THAT IF I MAY I JUST
WANTED TO START BY THANKING YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS NONE OF US
IN THE ASSEMBLY ARE ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH ANYTHING WITHOUT
LEANING ON EACH OTHER AND YOUR
WORK AS ACTING CHAIR WAS BOTH.
ADMIRABLE AND IMPRESSIVE I
ENJOYED WATCHING YOU AND
LISTENING TO YOU AND THE WAY IN
WHICH YOU.
BROUGHT OUT A CONVERSATION BOTH
YOUR HUMOR AND THIS -- SHARP WIT
OR SOMETHING THAT I ENJOYED
WATCHING AND I DID WATCH EVERY
MOMENT OF SOMEONE IT'S SOMETHING
I'VE.
ALWAYS ENJOYED DOING.
I WANTED TO TALK ABOUT AN
ADVOCATE FOR A FEW OF THE ISSUES
THAT CAME BEFORE SUB ONE THAT
YOU APPROVED AND IF I MAY I
REALLY JUST WANTED TO TALK ABOUT.
HOW EXCITED I AM FOR THE
PROPOSALS THAT WE CAN ADVOCATE
FOR HERE TODAY? FOR MANY OF US
WE'VE BEEN FIGHTING FOR HEALTH
FOR ALL AND THAT VALUE THAT
HEALTHCARE IS A HUMAN RIGHT AND
I'M EXCITED THAT THE ASSEMBLY
HAS TAKEN THE FIRST STEPS TO
PUSH.
TOWARDS THAT GOAL AND THERE ARE
EXPANDING HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
TO ALL YOUNG ADULTS.
I'M ALSO -- HAVE BROUGHT BEFORE
THE ISSUE REGARDING THE AGEDAND
DISABLED PROGRAM AND HOW THERE'S
A BARRIER TO ACCESS -- AND HOW
AND HOW THIS INVESTMENT WILL
HELP OUR AGED AND DISABLED TO
ACCESS CARE.
WANTED TO TALK ABOUT BRIEFLY IF
I COULDTHE NEED FOR BEHAVIORAL --
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CURE NAVIGATORS MANY
TIMES PEOPLE JUST DON'T KNOW
WHERE TO GO.
AND THE TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
ONE TIME INVESTMENT WILL ALLOW
HOSPITALS.
TO REALIZE THE BENEFITS OF
HIRING THESE PEER NAVIGATORS AND
THE FINANCIAL INCENTIVE TO RE
HIRING ON AFTER THE GRANT.
IT'S A PROGRAM THAT'S SHOWING
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS -- AND
RESULTS HERE AT UC DAVIS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT.
MAY OF THE INVESTMENTS THAT YOU
MENTIONED REGARDING FRIDAY NIGHT
LIVES MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID.
MEDICAL INTERPRETERS AND TRAUMA
SCREENINGS ARE LONG OVERDUE AND
HELP US TO INCREASE ACCESS.
REGARDING THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH WE HAVE HAD AN
EPIDEMIC REGARDING STDS OR S. T.
EYES -- HABSI AND THE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLAR GOING INVESTMENTS
WHICH WILL IMPLEMENTINNOVATIVE
PREVENTION STRATEGIES IS LONG
OVERDUE.
IN REGARDS TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
I WAS IMPROVE I'M IMPRESSED WITH
THE INVESTMENT IN THE EARLY
PSYCHOSIS GRANTS SOME OF THE
INFORMATION THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
SEEING OUT OF NEW YORK SHOWS
THAT THESE INVESTMENTS MAY HELP
OUR STATE TO RECOGNIZE THOSE
SAME RESULTS.
THE ONGOING INVESTMENT IN THE
INNOVATION INCUBATOR
SPECIFICALLY WITHIN MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT MAY
ALLOW COUNTIES TO REALIZE AND
RECOGNIZE WHAT THE BEST
PRACTICES ARE.
IN ADDITION THE FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR INCENTIVE GRANTS TO
COUNTIES THAT ARE ON GOING WILL
ALSO ALLOW COUNTIES TO CONTINUE
TO INNOVATE AND FIGURE OUT WHT
OUR BEST PRACTICES.
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING I WAS.
PLEASED TO SEE THE INVESTMENTS
IN THE M. S. S. P. PROGRAM WHICH
HELPS US TO SAVE MONEY AS A
STATE AND ARE LONG OVERDUE FOR A
RATE INCREASE.
AS WELL AS THE INVESTMENT IN THE
SENIOR NUTRITION PROGRAM.
MANY OF OUR SENIORS LACK AN
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO GET A WARM
MEAL AND THE SENIOR NUTRITION
PROGRAM MAY BE THE ONLY WAY THEY
DO.
AND SO WAS VERY HAPPY WITH THAT.
WE HAVE ADVOCATED FOR THE LAST
THREE YEARS FOR RESTORATIONS OF
SOCIAL CAMPAñA RECKON THEM
PLEASE THAT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER WE WERE ABLE TO GET THAT
IN.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO HOW WE CAN
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE ID DE COMMUNITY IS
REPRESENTED AND IS HEARD HERE IN
OUR STATE CAPITOL.
I WANT TO MOVE ON TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES IF
I CAN AND TALK ABOUT A PROGRAM.
THAT I WAS PROUD WE GOT DONE
LAST YEAR IN WHICH I RECEIVED A
FRESH SHE FOR BUT IF I CAN I
WANTED TO SHARE THE FRESH SHE
WITH YOU IN A COLD ASK AS
BECAUSE OFTEN TIMES IT'S THE
WORK OF THE STAFF WHO.
PUTS IN ALL THE EFFORT THAT
MAKES THIS DONE.
CASH OUT EXTENDS.
FOOD STAMPS TO FOUR HUNDRED TO
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS AND SO THE
PERMANENCE THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
SEEN AND CREATING A PROGRAM THAT
MAKES SURE WERE.
PROVIDING BENEFITS TO ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITY IS IMPORTANT AND I WAS
REALLY EXCITED TO SEE HIM.
THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT JUSTICE
FELLOWSHIP WHICH IS -- GRANT
PROGRAM THAT WE FUNDED IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET WILL ALSO HELP
THOSE TO DEFEND AGAINST --
IMMIGRATION PROCEEDINGS.
WE KNOW THE IMPORTANCE THAT
DEFENSE PLAYS AND MAKING SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE HEARD IN A COURT
OF LAW.
AND WAS PLEASED THAT THIS
FELLOWSHIP MAY ALLOW PLACES LIKE
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. TO RECOGNIZE.
THE SAME BENEFITS TO COURT
REPRESENTATION THAT YOU COULD
GET IN LOS ANGELES OR SAN
FRANCISCO.
I TO WANT TO TALK ABOUT CAL
WORKS A PROGRAM THAT TOO OFTEN
AFFECTS WOMEN AND WOMEN OF COLOR.
AND THE EFFORTS THAT WE HAVE PUT
IN TO HELPING THE HOME VISITING
PROGRAM. TO MAKING THIS PROGRAM
APPLY NOT TO JUST FIRST TIME
MOTHERS OR MOTHERS -- UNDER THE
AGE OF TWENTY SIX BUT TO ALL
MOTHERS.
AS WELL AS THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE ON CAL WORKS THIS YEAR IN
TERMS OF THE EARNED INCOME
DISREGARD AND IN TERMS OF THE
ASSET TEST.
THESE ARE STRONG WAYS THAT WE
CAN BENEFIT THE CAL WORKS
PROGRAM BENEFITS WOMEN AND WOMEN
OF COLOR IN ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES.
FINALLY I WANTED AND WITH TWO IF
I COULD.
AND ITS FIRST.
THE FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE
SYSTEM WHICH WOULD ALLOW OR
FASTER FAMILIES TO BE ABLE TO
CONTACT A SOCIAL WORKER INSTEAD
OF CONTACTING THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
WILL ALLOW US TO BE ABLE TO GET
THEM THE RESOURCES THAT THEY
NEED AND THE TIME THAT THEY NEED.
I BELIEVE THAT THE FAMILY OR TO
RESPONSE SYSTEM SHOULD HAVE BEEN
SIGNED INTO LAW LAST YEAR BUT
GOVERNOR BROWN.
AND I'M PLEASED THAT WE FOUND IT
WITHIN OUR BUDGET THIS YEAR TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION AND LOOK FORWARD TO
THE GOVERNOR HOPEFULLY ADOPTING
THIS.
ON JUNE FIFTEENTH.
BUT I WANTED TO END WITH THE
YOUTH AND FAMILY CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT INITIATIVE WHICH IS
PUSHED BY THE LOTUS WORK DONE
THE MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
FREEDOM CENTER.
THE IMPORTANCE OF YOUTH AND
FAMILY IS GETTING INVOLVED IN
ADVOCACY OF SOMETHING THAT'S NOT
LOST ON ME.
I GREW UP HAVING LEARNED THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING A VOICE AND
FIGHTING FOR THOSE WHO DON'T.
AND IT'S PROGRAMS LIKE THIS THAT
CONTINUE.
TO INVEST IN FUTURE ADVOCATES
THAT WILL ALLOW COMMUNITIES TO
FEEL.
LIKE THIS GOVERNMENT IS WORKING
FOR THEM.
SO I JUST WANTED TO THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAY AS FOR ALL
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE ALL
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AS
WELL AS THE STAFF -- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WERE GOING TO GO TO A
MISSED MCCARTY NOW FOR A BRIEF --
PRESENTATIONS UP TO YES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANTED
TO PRESENT OUR ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUB -- TO PACKAGE HERE FOR THE
FULL COMMITTEE FOR SALT WHEN I
THINK ARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
SOMEONE MEMBERS THE DENALI MON
MARK SU CHI O'DONNELL GALLAGHER
AND BRO FOR PARTICIPATING WE HAD
FIFTY HOURS.
OF TESTIMONY A LOT OF PUBLIC
COMMENT THIRTEEN HEARINGS ALSO
THE TOP WHEN I THINK ARE GREAT --
COMMITTEE STAFF MARK MARTIN
KATIE HARTMAN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HARD WORK IS ALWAYS.
AND OUR PLAN HERE -- FOCUS ON
WHAT WE THINK IS THE TOP ISSUE
IN CALIFORNIA VESTING IN OUR
PUBLIC EDUCATION FROM EARLY
EDUCATION ALL THE WAY THROUGH
COLLEGE. TO SAKE HIGHLIGHTS
INCLUDE STARTING WITH OUR K. --
TWELVE BUDGETS WE FOCUS THIS IS
AN ATTACK ON TOP OF THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL MONIES TO PAY
DOWN.
THE PENSION OBLIGATIONS FOR OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND COMMUNICATE
DISTRICTS HELP THEM -- TO
ACCLIMATE TO THE RISING PENSION
OTHER COSTS WE HAVE ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION. FOR THAT PURPOSE
BY DOWN.
WE FIND THE GOVERNOR'S LC IF
THAT BUDGET PLUS PUT SOME MONEY
ON TOP OF THIS ALL THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY TWO MILLION TO HELP
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
A TOP ISSUE FOR DISTRICTS WE'VE
BEEN HEARING IS SPECIAL LEAD.
WE PUT THE MONEY FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ROUGHLY SIX
HUNDRED MILLION.
BUT FOCUSED ON I THINK A MORE
PRUDENT PLAN WITH EQUALIZATION
AS WELL AS SOME MONEY FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION PRESCHOOL.
AS WELL WE PROVIDE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
TO IMPROVE OR ELSE IF THEY HAVE
TO HELP FUND THE LOWEST
PERFORMING STUDENTS IN THAT
SUBGROUP SO WHERE YOU KNOW
PROBABLY CONTINUING THAT EFFORT --
EARLY EDUCATION WE KNOW THAT
THAT PRE K. CHILD CARE APPROVING
DIFFERENCE MAKERS WERE PLEASE
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND
GO ABOVE THAT.
SOME WE HAVE A BILLION DOLLARS
IN ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR EARLY
AT INCLUDE INCLUDING. THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY ON GOING WHICH
IS NOT INCLUDED HIGHLIGHTS
INCLUDE ADDING. THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
ADDITIONAL CHILDCARE SLOTS
REGIONAL CHILD CARE AND THE
VOUCHER PROGRAM IN ADDITION TO
THAT TEN THOUSAND FULL DAY
PRESCHOOLS COSTS THAT ARE
ALREADY -- IN THE BUDGET WE
APPROVE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS
FOR ONE TIME INVESTMENTS FOR
CHILD CARE FACILITIES AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT WAS SOME
SLIGHT MODIFICATIONS AND
IMPLEMENTATION. FOR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS WE WANTED TO SAY THAT
WE HEARD THE VOTERS LADEN KEEP
CLEAR WITH PROP.
SIXTY FOUR THAT WE SHOULD USE
THOSE RESOURCES THAT OF COURSE
IS THE MARIJUANA MONEY. FOR
FOCUSING ON OUR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAM SO WE INCLUDE EIGHTY
MILLION TO HELP OUR ASUS
PROGRAMS ACROSS.
CALIFORNIA AND WE ALSO DEAL WITH
ARE INADEQUATE RATES FOR OUR
CHILD CARE AND PRESCHOOL
PROVIDERS SO MODERNIZE THEM.
AND PROVIDE A SLIGHT ADJUSTMENT.
MOVING ON TO HIGHER ED.
ON OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE --
PACKAGE WE FUND THE SECOND CHEER
OF OUR COLLEGE PROMISE THAT OF
COURSE IS FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FOR THE FIRST TIME FULL TIME
STUDENTS NOW WILL BE YEAR ONE
AND YEAR -- TWO WITH REGARD TO
THE ONLINE COLLEGE WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT SOME PROGRAMS
IN A SECOND YEAR.
WE FELT IT HAD -- IT WAS OVER
FUNDED IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET AND
WE HAD OTHER PRIORITIES SO WE'RE
KEEPING THE ONLINE CALLS ARE
REDIRECTING SOME OF THE OVER
PREPARATION FROM LAST YEAR TO
OTHER PRIORITIES SUCH AS VETERAN
RESOURCE CENTERS -- STUDENT --
SERVICE PROGRAMS LIKE TWENTY
ANIMO JOB AS WELL AS IMPROVING
PART TIME FACULTY OFFICE HOURS
CAN INCREASING.
FULL TIME FACULTY. FOR OUR UC
AND CSU -- BUDGETS -- NEVER A
PERFECT BUDGET FOR FOR THESE --
HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS WE
HEAR THAT ALL THE TIME.
BUT I WILL KNOW THAT THIS IS THE
HIGHEST FUNDING GROWTH FOR BOTH
SEGMENTS IN THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS.
SO THAT SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
NOTE -- WE SUPPORT MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND NEW SLOTS FOR UC AND
CSU STUDENTS TOP PRIORITY BACK
HOME FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS.
NOW WE ALSO FOCUS ON UC'S TOP
PRIORITY PROVIDING THEM WITH
NINETY FIVE MILLION ON TOP OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND AT CSU
WE FIND.
THE GRAD INITIATIVE -- LASTLY
AND FINANCIAL AID.
WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE THE ENVIOUS
CAL GRANT PROGRAM BUT WE
UNFORTUNATELY TOO MANY STUDENTS
BEHIND SO WE AT FORTY THOUSAND
MORE COMPETITIVE CAL GRANTS.
AND WE FOCUS ON INCREASING AID
FOR STUDENTS TO GO TO SCHOOL IN
THE SUMMER WHO ARE CAL GRANT
RECIPIENTS AND THIS CERTAINLY
HELPS GET US TO OUR PATH FOR
DEBT FREE COLLEGE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO THIS WRAPS UP ARE SAID TO
BUDGET PLAN AND LOOK FORWARD TO
TAKING THIS THE NEXT NEXT ABSENT.
AND FINALIZE OUR BUDGET THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU BEFORE WE GO TO MISTER
BLOOM WE'RE GONNA TAKE ROLE
[inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
CHIU COOPER [inaudible]
FONG.
FRAZIER.
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GARCIA.
JONES SAWYER HERE LACKEY LOW
MOAN [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ.
MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI.
THIS AREA [inaudible]
O'DONNELL PATTERSON [inaudible]
MOST [inaudible]
RAY YES.
RIVAS.
RUBIO HERE STONE [inaudible]
UBER [inaudible]
WICKS [inaudible]
WHAT?
HOME IS PRESENT THANK YOU MISTER
BUSH.
MISTER CHAIR AND MISTER VICE
CHAIR THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR
ALL A GREAT LEADERSHIP THIS YEAR
I DON'T THINK WE OFTEN THINK
ABOUT THE PRODIGIOUS AMOUNT OF
TIME THAT -- THAT OUR LEADERSHIP
PUT SAND AND TO IT REALLY SHOWS
IN THE ULTIMATE TO A PRODUCT
THAT COMES OUT EVERY YEAR -- I
ALSO WANT.
TO THANK GOD REALLY THE ENTIRE
BUDGET STAFF FROM -- MISTER --
SAYS NAME MISTER GRIFFITH -- ON
DOWN -- THROUGH THE STAFF THAT
WE WORK WITH DIRECTLY IN MY CASE
THAT'S A FAIR BRACTON SUSAN
CHANT.
OF WHO WERE THERE ARE SIDE BY
SIDE WITH US AT EVERY EVERY
MINUTE -- THAT'S ON THE ASSEMBLY
[inaudible]
OKAY.
CASE PROLONGED ALSO -- AS AN
AUNT AND I SHOULD JUST SAY THAT --
THE INPUT AND INSIGHT THAT WE
GET FROM THE LA -- IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS REALLY
A INVALUABLE OF COURSE A LITTLE
MORE OF FROM THE LA -- THAN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THAT -- THAT HEALTHY TENSION IS
ACTUALLY GREAT -- FOR THE FOR
THE PROCESS THAT WE HAVE AND THE
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION THAT WE
HAVE IN IN SUB THREE I DON'T GET
A CHANCE.
TO ATTEND THE MEETING SO FROM
THE OTHER -- SUBCOMMITTEES BUT
I'M SURE IT'S AS ROBUST AS IT IS --
IN AS IT IS IN SUB THREE AND
IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND
FINALLY I WANT TO THANK THE A
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS -- OF FOR
YOUR COLLEGIALITY AND GENERALLY
CONCISE -- ENDS IN SIGHT SO THAT
YOU PROVIDE DURING THE COURSE OF
OF OUR HEARINGS -- MISTER
PATTERSON MISTER FONG MS GARCIA
MISTER MULLIN MS RIVAS AND AS
REYES THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- IT
WAS ANOTHER BUSY YEAR FOR SUB --
THREE WE TOOK A NUMBER OF
ACTIONS TO ADDRESS CHALLENGES IN
THE AREA OF NATURAL RESOURCES
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION ENERGY
AND TRANSPORTATION SOME OF THOSE
ACTIONS -- FALL INTO A NUMBER OF
CATEGORIES -- BEGINNING WITH
WILDFIRE RECOVERY IN RESPONSE.
THE COMMITTEE APPROVED A NUMBER
OF PROPOSALS INTENDED TO AID IN
THE STATE'S ABILITY TO RESPOND
AND ASSIST LOCALS.
DURING QUALIFIER INCIDENTS.
OF THIS INCLUDES ESTABLISHING A
PERMANENT DEBRIS REMOVAL UNIT AT
CAL RECYCLE AND AN EMERGENCY
RESPONSE UNIT AT THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
SUB THREE RESOURCES FOR WILD
FIRE AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE WITH
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE TO ENSURE
THE DEPARTMENTS RESPONSIBLE FOR
FUEL REDUCTION PROJECTS ARE
COORDINATING ON ALL THESE
ACTIVITIES.
THE SUBCOMMITTEE MADE
MODIFICATIONS TO THE WELFARE
PROPOSALS RELATED TO UTILITIES
COMPLYING WITH THEIR WELFARE
MITIGATION PLANS AND ONLY
APPROVED THE FUNDING.
RELATED TO SAFETY AND
ENFORCEMENT FOR TWO YEARS AS
OPPOSED TO ON GOING.
THE SUBCOMMITTEE ALSO ADOPTED
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONSIDER.
IF THE PROPOSED FRAMEWORK IS
APPROPRIATE FOR THESE NEW
ACTIVITIES.
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER CONTINUES TO BE AN ISSUE
THAT -- WE STRUGGLE WITH MANY
CALIFORNIANS AS YOU ALL KNOW DO
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE DRINKING
WATER AND MUST RELY ON
PURCHASING WATER AND HAULING IT
INTO THEIR HOMES.
A SUSTAINABLE FRAMEWORK IS
NEEDED TO PERMANENTLY SOLVE THIS
CRISIS THERE ARE NUMBER OF
POLICY BILLS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
BEING CONSIDERED BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
INCLUDING ONE OF MY OWN AND AS
SUCH SO THREE HAS DECIDED TO
DEFER TO THE POLICY BILL PROCESS
ON CREATING A SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
PROGRAM AND WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT
THAT WILL WORK OUT.
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH FROM
HAZARDOUS WASTE DTS SEE IS FACED
WITH THE BUDGET SHORTFALL IN THE
CURRENT YEAR AND IN ADDITION TO
FISCAL ISSUES DTS SEE ALSO FACES
CRITICISMS.
OVER THERE LONG PERMIT
PROCESSING TIMES POOR
ENFORCEMENT AND DELAYED SITE
REMEDIATION.
SO SUB THREE APPROVED THE BUDGET
YOU'RE FUNDING FOR DTS SEE AN
ADOPTED PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AT THE TSC.
SUB THREE ADOPTED A ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLAR CAP AND
TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN THAT UP
HOLDS THE ASSEMBLIES COMMITMENT
TO INVESTING IN PROGRAMS THAT
ADDRESS AIR POLLUTANTS.
MITIGATION AND RESILIENCE AND
LOW CARBON TRANSPORTATION.
AND FINALLY -- IMPROVING THE DMV
IS A PRIORITY FOR US AND SUB
THREE MODIFIED THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL FOR
OPERATIONAL IMPROVEMENTS AT THE
DMV.
AND APPROVED THE EXPENDITURE OF
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
INSTEAD OF THE TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY TWO MILLIONDOLLARS THAT
WAS PROPOSED. TO FUND ALL
EXISTING AND RECENTLY HEARD
STAFF AND NEW HIRES THAT ARE
ALREADY UNDER WAY.
AND TO FIND ALL PROPOSALS FOR
CUSTOMER SERVICE IMPROVEMENTS
OPERATIONAL IMPROVEMENTS AND I.
T. IMPROVEMENTS.
THIS APPROACH HOLDS BACK ABOUT
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS AND THE
EQUIVALENT OF FOUR HUNDRED
POSITIONS THAT WERE REQUESTED BY
THE ADMINISTRATION.
THE ASSEMBLY WILL PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT IN THE UPCOMING BUDGET
YEAR AND HOLD DMV ACCOUNTABLE TO
AGREED UPON PERFORMANCE METRICS
AND WILL WORK CLOSELY WITH THE
MV. TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES IF IT IS EFFECTIVELY
IMPLEMENTED THE RESOURCES THAT
IT HAS ALREADY BEEN GIVEN.
THAT CONCLUDES MY REPORT THANK
YOU AGAIN.
MISTER MISTER COOPER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
I WANT TO FIRST ACKNOWLEDGE THE
MEMBERS THE SUB FOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS CHIU NAZARIAN
WICKS AND LACKEY.
AND THE FOR TACKLING MAJOR
PARTIES WITH SOME OF THIS YEAR.
AND FOR OUR BUDGET STAFF AMAZING
FOLKS CHRISTIAN GEN V. FERA AND
KATIE THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH A
ROCK STARS.
SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR WHO'S TO SOME
OF THE LARGEST AND MOST
AMBITIOUS PROPOSALS CONTAINED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THESE INCLUDE TWO POINT FOUR
BILLION HOUSING AND ALMOST
PACKAGE WHICH BILLS ON THE
INVESTMENT MADE LAST YEAR.
THE PACKAGE INCLUDES SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION IN HOMELESSNESS
FUNDING SEVEN FIFTY MILLION IN
PLANNING AND PRODUCTION GRANTS.
IN FIVE THREE MILLION TO EXPAND
THE LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDIT.
IN FIVE HUNDRED MILLION TO
ENCOURAGE DEVELOPMENT OF A LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME HOUSING. ONE
BILLION EXPANSION OF THE EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT INCREASING THE
CURRENT PROGRAM BY OVER WITHIN A
50% NEXT DAY THE PROGRAM TO
COVER CALIFORNIA WORKERS.
WITHOUT A TAX IDENTIFIER.
HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION FOR
SINCE IT'S NOT REACH ACTIVITIES
INCLUDING LABOR TAXES MATERIALS.
LOCAL A COMMUNITY BASED OUTREACH
EFFORTS AN EXTENSIVE TARGETED
MEDIA CAMPAIGN. EIGHTY SEVEN
POINT THREE MILLION TO HELP
INSURE THAT COUNTIES HAVE
ADEQUATE FUNDING TO REPLACE
THEIR OUTDATED COUNTY ELECTION
SYSTEMS.
THIS LEVEL FOR THE COMBINED
LATCHES INVESTMENT OF A HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR MILLION.
BRING THE STATE'S TOTAL
INVESTMENT 275% OF TOTAL
ESTIMATED COST.
THE SUBCOMMITTEE DIFFERS FROM
THE GOVERNOR ON A FEW KEY AREAS.
ASSEMBLY TOOK ACTION IS A FOR
THE POST PAID FAMILY LEAVE
EXPANSION TO THE POLICY PROCESS
REFLECTING PROGRESS MADE RECENT
POLICY BILLS TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE.
AND EXCLUDES TESTING FOR ME
PROVISIONS FOR THE PACKAGE
REFLECTION IS AYE ART OF THE
ASSEMBLY TO ALLOW MORE
DELIBERATIONS ON THE COMPLEX
PACKAGE OF ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION.
INTEREST TAX ELEMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK MISS COOPER A DOCTOR WEBER
AND WHATDOCTOR WEBER SPEAKING
LIKE TO ASK -- FINANCING ONLY AT
A CLUB PLACE.
THANK YOU -- BEFORE I START I
WANT OF COURSE THANK THE SPEAKER
OF FOR HIS EFFORTS AND WORK AS
WELL AS A SELECTION.
AND OF THE MEMBERS ON MY
COMMITTEE WHO I THINK ARE --
WERE EXCELLENT IN TERMS OF BEING
ABLE TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT
WE FACE -- TO AND AND PRIORITIZE
OUR WORK ONE THING WAS DETAINED
FOR HIS ONGOING SUPPORT AND
COUNSEL AS WELL AS THE MANY
MEETINGS WE HAD TO TALK ABOUT
THE FUTURE OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND THE KINDS OF CHALLENGES THAT
WE FACE AND HOW WE'RE OBVIOUSLY
GOING TO MAKE SOME REFORM -- I
WANT TO THANK US THAT MY
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP IN DEVELOPING PUBLIC
SAFETY BUDGET PRIORITIES THAT
REFLECT OUR VALUES.
OF INVESTING IN RESOURCES THAT
PROMOTE SAFER COMMUNITIES I WANT
TO THANK MISTER STONE WHO I
COULD ALWAYS COUNT ON TO BE
THEIR FIRST OF WHICH IS FOR
BEING THE GOOD CHAMPION OF
JUSTICE FOR ALL IN OUR COURT
SYSTEM.
AND MOST OF YOU KNOW WE HAVE WE
ALWAYS AVE DIFFICULTY GETTING
PEOPLE THERE BECAUSE OUR
MEETINGS WERE AT THE SAME TIME
THAT THERE WAS SO MANY OTHER
D SO
AND OUT BUT NONE THE LESS ALL
FIVE OF THEM WERE REALLY
COMMITTED.
TO BEING ON THE COMMITTEE
SOMEONE THING WAS TO STONE -- I
CAN ALWAYS COUNT TO BE THERE
MISTER JONES SAWYER FOR HIS DEEP
COMMITMENT TO OUR AT PROMISE
STUDENTS AND HIS HARD WORK AND
HIS HISTORY OF OF HAVING SERVED
IN PUBLIC SAFETY TO GIVE US SOME
BALANCE.
AND PERSPECTIVE THING WAS TO
LACKEY FOR PROVIDING HIS LAW
ENFORCEMENT EXPERIENCE FOR US
AND PERSPECTIVE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
AND MISS MELENDEZ WASN'T AS
WILLIAM MEETINGS AT THE SAME
TIME.
BUT NONE THE LESS HER PASSION IS
STRONG ADVOCACY WAS ALWAYS THERE
ONE OF THANK ARE REPUBLICAN
CONSULTANT I DON'T HAVE HIS NAME
DOWN HERE BUT HE ALWAYS ANSWERED
THE FAMOUS QUESTION ARE THEY
COMING.
AND ANY ALWAYS TOLD ME THE SAME
THING I DON'T CONTROL THEM I
ONLY GET INFORMATION WHICH WAS
GOOD -- SO I WON'T HAVE TO
ASKING THAT QUESTION ANYMORE
MONDAY AFTERNOON FOR WHILE --
LESSON ONE THING MIGHT
CONSULTANT STAFF JENNIFER CAM
FOR HER TIRELESS WORK AND
COUNSEL AND INTEREST IN THIS
FIELD.
AND HER BIG ABILITY TO DIG
REALLY DEEP AND GET BEYOND THE
THAT THE SURFACE TO TALK ABOUT.
WHAT OUR GOALS WERE WHAT HOW
THIS WAS PARTICULARLY UP
IMPACTING THAT AND WITHIN THAT
WE WERE MAKING PROGRESS?
THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
ON PUBLIC SAFETY HAS HAS MADE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN TO
ENSURE IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY
OUTCOMES.
AND GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY OVER
PROGRAMS AND EXPENDITURES WE
SPENT QUITE A BIT OF TIME
TALKING ABOUT THE VARIOUS
PROGRAMS THAT WE PUT IN PLACE
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS.
AND WHETHER NOT THEY ACHIEVING
THE GOALS THAT WE SET AND BEING
VERY HONEST ABOUT WITHIN THAT WE
WERE ACTUALLY REDUCING
RECIDIVISM OR WHETHER PEOPLE
JUST COMPLYING WITH PROGRAMS
WITHOUT THINKING ABOUT THE
OUTCOME.
SO WE HAVE VERY GOOD
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT IN VERY
GOOD RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
USE A DOLLARS IN THE FUTURE.
BASICALLY TO ACCOMPLISH THAT --
AMONG OUR MANY ACTIONS WE
APPROVE THE TRANSITION OF THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
FROM CDC ARE TO HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY.
AB AND THAT IN ITSELF WAS A A A
QUITE A CHALLENGE BECAUSE WE OF
THOUGHT AS A COMMITTEE THAT WE
REALLY DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME
TO MAKE SUCH A MAJOR MOVE.
AND SO WHAT WE'VE DONE IS WE'VE
CREATED ADVISORY BODY TO ADDRESS
YOU'VE DELINQUENCY THROUGH A
TRAUMA INFORMED REHABILITATION
FOCUS LANDS.
WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT THE
TRANSITION BUT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S DONE RIGHT.
AND THAT WOULD JUST NOT MOVING
FROM ONE BUILDING TO THE NEXT
AND CARING THE SAME PROGRAMS
FORWARD AND IN THE UP WITH THE
SAME RESULTS.
WE'VE ALSO MADE A CRITICAL
INVESTMENT TO ADDRESS THE HIGH
RATE OF DEATH OCCURRING FROM
DRUG OVERDOSES IN OUR PRISONS --
BUT WE ARE PROPOSING TO DO IT IN
A MANNER THAT WE BELIEVE THAT
WILL DELIVER THE BEST RESULTS.
ADDRESSING THE FLOW OF DRUGS
INTO THE PRISON SCALING THE
TREATMENT IN A WAY WHERE CDC ARE
CAN SUCCESSFULLY REDUCE
OVERDOSES AND ENSURING THAT
COUNTY PARTNERS ABLE TO PROVIDE
TRANSITION SUPPORT ONCE A PERSON
IS RELEASED. TO ENHANCE ACCESS
TO JUSTICE IN OUR COURTS WHICH
IS BEEN AN ONGOING CHALLENGE BY
THIS COMMITTEE AND WE'RE PROUD
OF THE FACT THAT OVER THE LAST
YEAR AND THIS YEAR AS WELL.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO ADD
ADDITIONAL WE THIS IS -- TO OUR
JET BUT TO OUR JUDGESHIPS IN
TERMS OF OF OVERSIGHT AS WELL AS
PARTICULARLY DEALING WITH COURT
REPORTERS AND A NUMBER OF OTHER
SUPPORT SERVICES FOR JUDGES --
WE'VE OF THIS YEAR WE ENHANCE
THE BY RECREATING TWENTY FIVE
NEW JUDGESHIPS TO BE DISTRIBUTED
IN AREAS WHERE THE GREATEST NEED
AND WE PROVIDED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR DEPENDENCY COUNCIL.
SO WE'RE VERY PROUD OF THAT
BECAUSE THAT'S BEEN AN ISSUE
THAT'S BEEN RAISED EVERY YET
EVEN THOUGH IN PROVIDING THE
TWENTY FIVE WE STILL A SHORT IN
TERMS OF THE JUDGES NEEDED AND
STATE TO ENSURE.
THAT THERE IS ADEQUATE ACCESS
AND THEREFORE ADEQUATE JUSTICE.
UNPRECEDENTED DISASTERS HAVE
REQUIRED SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
IN DISASTER RELIEF IN RESPONSE.
WE PROVIDED AN ADDITIONAL THREE
HUNDRED MILLION INVESTMENTS
INCLUDING PRE PUT THE PRE
POSITIONING OF FIRED EQUIPMENT
WE ALSO SUPPORTED UPDATING THE
NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM AND THE
COMPLETION OF THE EARLY
EARTHQUAKE WARNING SYSTEM.
OTHER IMPORTANT THIS INSTANT I
WERE MADE INCLUDING MORE FUNDING
FOR THE USE OF FORCE TRAINING
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT ON GOING
GRANTS TO PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
FOR VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
REINSTATING AUDITING AND
INVESTED KATORI FUNCTIONS OF THE
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL AND
PILOT I'M PILOTING PRE TRIAL
SERVICES IN IN TEN COUNTIES.
I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE WHO
WORKED SO HARD IN THIS ALL OF
THOSE WHO CAME TO THE HEARINGS
IN MAY TESTIMONY BEFORE US AND
THE ADVOCATES WHO OBVIOUSLY MET
WITH ME MANY TIMES TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE UNDERSTOOD.
JUST HOW IMPORTANT THEIR
PROGRAMS THAT WERE AND HOW
IMPORTANT FUNDING WAS THAT WE
WERE PROVIDING THEM -- IF FOR
MORE INFORMATION OBVIOUSLY LOOK
AT THE REPORT THAT A LONG LIST
OF THINGS THAT WE FUND IT I KNOW
YOU DON'T WANT ME TO READ THOSE
GUYS WILL GLOSS OVER -- BUT I'M
JUST WANT TO THANK OUR THOSE
STAFF AND EVERYONE WHO WORK WITH
US TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN VERY
POSITIVE OUTCOME THIS YEAR THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU DOCTOR MR OBERNOLTE.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- I
WOULD LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF THE CHAIR.
IN THANKING EVERYONE THAT'S BEEN
INVOLVED IN THE BUDGET PROCESS
THIS YEAR I REMAIN CONVINCED
THAT CRAFTING THE BUDGET IS THE
SINGLE MOST INFLUENTIAL THING
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE DOES EVERY
YEAR.
DISTRIBUTING THAT OVER TWO
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS OF
TAXPAYER REVENUE HAS PROFOUND
CONSEQUENCES FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
WE SERVE.
AND THAT'S WHY I THINK THAT THIS
COMMITTEE IS SO IMPORTANT IN THE
ASSEMBLY -- SO THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR HARD WORK ON THE BUDGET --
I THINK THAT FOR THE PEOPLE
OUTSIDE THE BUDGET PROCESS THEY
DON'T REALIZE HOW MUCH WORK IT
IS TO SERVE ON A BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE BUT IF YOU TAKE A
JOB SERIOUSLY AND I'M CONVINCED
EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM DOES -- IT
IS A LOT OF WORK AND I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR HER
WALK EFFORTS AND THE STAFF
THAT'S BEEN INVOLVED IN
SUPPORTING THEM.
I ALSO ACTUALLY THINK THAT THIS
IS THERE'S A LOT TO LIKE IN THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET THIS YEAR.
I I DON'T THINK IT'S AN
EXAGGERATION TO SAY IT IS A MUCH
MORE FISCALLY PRUDENT BUDGET
THAN THE ONE THAT'S EITHER
COMING OUT OF THE SENATE OR THE
ONE THAT WAS PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR AND I THINK THOSE ARE --
REALLY GREAT THINGS -- HOWEVER I
HAVE A COUPLE OF CONCERNS.
AND ONE OF THE MOMENT TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING ELSE THAT I LIKE --
THE THE GOVERNOR ISLA REALLY
WANT TO COMMEND THE ASSEMBLY FOR
PUSHING BACK ON THE
ADMINISTRATION IN CHARACTERIZING
SOME OF THE EXPENDITURES AS ONE
TIME.
I THINK THE GOVERNOR TOLD US ALL
THAT 11% OF THE SPENDING
INCREASE WAS ONE TIME AND 89%
I'M SORRY WHAT ONLY 11% WAS --
ONGOING 89% WAS ONE TIME.
AND I THOUGHT THAT THAT WAS AN
UNFAIR CHARACTERIZATION BECAUSE
WHEN YOU PUT A SUNSET ON
SOMETHING LIKE ON AYE HSS
PROVIDER.
RATE INCREASE OR A TEST SALES
TAX EXEMPTION FOR DIAPERS AND
TAMPONS WE KNOW THAT THOSE
THINGS ARE GOING TO BE ROLLED
BACK IN FUTURE YEARS SO. TO SAY
THAT THAT'S ONE TIME EXPENDITURE
IS -- IS I THINK NOT REALLY
CHARACTERIZING IT RIGHT AND TO
THE FOR THE MOST PART THIS BODY
WHEN WE CRAFT OUR BUDGET HAS
RESISTED THE TEMPTATION TO DO
THAT.
AND I REALLY THINK THAT THAT'S A
GREAT THING.
ALSO I AM VERY THANKFUL THAT WE
ARE TAKING THE THREAT OF
RECESSION AND ITS CONSEQUENT
IMPACT ON STATE REVENUE
SERIOUSLY IN THIS BUDGET WE
CONTINUE TO MAKE PRUDENT
VESTMENTS AND OUR STATE RESERVES --
IF DEPENDING ON HOW THE DUST
SETTLES I THINK WE'RE GONNA WIND
UP AT THE END OF THIS FISCAL
YEAR WITH A LITTLE BIT MORE THAN
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS IN
RESERVE.
WHICH WILL BE THE LARGEST
RESERVE IN CALIFORNIA STATE
HISTORY.
THOSE ARE GREAT THINGS HOWEVER I
ALSOTHINK WE NEED TO BE MINDFUL
THAT THE LA -- TELLS US THAT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE IN A MODEST
RECESSION ABOUT SEVENTY BILLION
DOLLARS OF OVERALL REVENUE LOSS.
AND EVEN WHEN YOU BALANCE OUT
THINGS LIKE THE DECLINING IN THE
PROP NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEES
THAT STILL GOING TO HAVE AN OVER
FORTY BILLION DOLLAR IMPACT ON
OUR BUDGET SO. TO PUT THAT IN
CONTEXT WE ARE ABOUT IF IF OUR
GOAL IS TO HAVE ENOUGH REVENUE
TO WHETHER A MODEST RECESSION
WITHOUT CUTTING PROGRAMS WE'RE
ABOUT HALFWAY THERE.
SO -- IT'S GREAT THAT WE'RE ON
THIS PATH AND I WANT TO CONTINUE
TO TO DO THAT.
I ALSO WANT TO TALK AGAIN AS I
HAVE IN THE PAST ABOUT THE WAY
THAT THOSE RESERVES ARE
STRUCTURED.
THE THE JUST A FEW SHORT YEARS
AGO WE ONLY HAD A SINGLE STATE
RESERVE FUND THE SPECIAL FUND
FOR ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTIES.
AND THERE IS A PROVISION IN
STATE LAW THE SAYS THAT WHEN THE
BALANCE IN THE SFE YOU GETS
ABOVE 3% OF GENERAL FUND
REVENUES.
STATE SALES TAXES OPPOSED TO GO
DOWN ONE QUARTER OF A PERCENTAGE
POINT.
AND THAT'S SUPPOSED TO GIVE THE
TAXPAYERS OF CALIFORNIA A BREAK
ON SALES TAX IN YEARS WHEN.
THE STATE HAS A LOT OF REVENUE
AND I WE'VE CREATED LOTS OF
DIFFERENT RESERVES NOW THE
RESERVES ARE SOCIAL SAFETY NETS
RESERVE CREATED BY THE VOTERS.
BUT THE CONSEQUENCE OF THAT HAS
BEEN THAT THE PEOPLE CALIFORNIA
HAVE NOT SEEN THAT SALES TAX
RIGHT RATE CUT AND I REALLY
STRONGLY THINK THAT THEY SHOULD --
I JUST WANNA TAKE ONE MINUTE TO
TALK ABOUT EDUCATION FUNDING
BECAUSE THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
I'VE BEEN VERY FRUSTRATED ABOUT.
THIS BUDGET FUNDS A MODEST
INCREASE IN THE PER CAPITA K.
TWELVE EDUCATION SPENDING IT'LL
BE ABOUT.
TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
STUDENT A LITTLE BIT MORE THAN
THAT WHEN -- THIS BUDGET PASSES.
TO PUT IN CONTEXT THAT'S FORTY
FIRST IN THE NATION EVEN WITH
THAT INCREASE.
AND THE CONSEQUENCE OF HAVING.
K. TWELVE EDUCATION FUNDED AT
THAT LOW LEVEL ARE MANIFOLD WE
ARE FORTY SIX THE AND READING
TEST SCORES WERE FORTY SEVENTH
AND MATH WE HAVE THE LOWEST.
STUDENT TO TEACHER RATIO THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY.
AND THAT IS UNACCEPTABLE AND I
KNOW THIS IS NOT A PARTISAN
ISSUE I KNOW EVERYONE AGREES
THAT IS UNACCEPTABLE -- WE HAVE
A BILL IN THE LEGISLATURE THAT --
MISTER CARTY AND I AM MISTER
MERCHANTS YEAR OLD JOIN AUTHOR
OF ITS A. B. THIRTY NINE THAT
STATES THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO RAISE THAT.
PER STUDENT SPENDING RATIO UP TO
AT LEAST.
THE MIDDLE OF THE AVERAGE FOR
STATES.
BUT THAT IS NEVER GOING TO GET
DONE AND LESS WE HAVE THE
POLITICAL WILL TO DO IT AND
EVERY TIME THAT WE FIND ANOTHER
PROGRAM.
AND IT'S VERY SEDUCTIVE WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION WE TALK BOUT SCHOOL
BREAKFAST WE TALK ABOUT AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS BUT EVERY TIME
WE FIND ONE OF THOSE PROGRAMS
THAT WE TAKE AWAY DOLLARS THAT
WE COULD HAVE SPENT.
TOWARDS MEETING THE PRIMARY
COMMITMENT THAT WE HAVE TO
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT I REMAIN VERY
FRUSTRATED ABOUT AND I'M HOPEFUL
IN FUTURE YEARS THAT WE CAN TAKE
STEPS TOWARDS.
REMAINING THAT SITUATION SO --
THIS BILL THIS BUDGET OBVIOUSLY
HAS SOME GOOD PARTS AND SO BAD
PARTS -- I WILL BE OF STANDING
ON THE VOTE IN THE HOPES THAT WE
CAN WORK OUT SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT I HAVE OBJECTIONS TO IN THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE PROCESS BUT
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON THE
BUDGET AND FOR ALL OF THE
BUDGETS SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF THAT
WE SERVE WITH.
THANK YOU MISTER FOSTER I THINK
IT'S A REMINDER THAT THE OVERALL
WITHIN THE BUDGET THERE'S A MOST
OF IT WE AGREE ON AND THE LARGE
MAJORITY THAT WE AGREE ON
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S STILL.
SOME DIFFERENCES AS YOU AS
HIGHLIGHTED -- TO IRON OUT THAT
BUT AGAIN WE BELIEVE THAT.
OF THE THREE BY JUST THIS IS THE
MOST FISCALLY PRUDENT BUDGET --
AND IT'S ALSO THE BUDGET THAT
AGAIN HAS PRIORITIZE EDUCATION
THE MOST.
AT THE SAME TIME IS REALLY
PREPARING US FOR THE FUTURE.
WITHOUT I KNOW DOCTOR WOULD HAVE
TO QUESTION AND THEN MISTER
COOPER.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AND I AND MY QUESTION WAS
AND I ACTUALLY YOU WERE ABLE TO
POINT OUT TO ME AND THAT WAS
REGARDING THE IN CO TAX
EXTENSION -- I KNOW I'VE SPOKEN
ABOUT THIS SEVERAL TIMES AND I'M
GLAD TO SEE THAT IT'S ON PAGE
SIX OF OF OF OF THE OVER HERE.
I BELIEVE IT'S IMPORTANT TO ONCE
AGAIN -- POINT OUT THAT -- BY
NOT PURSUING THE EXTENSION WE AS
THE ELLIE ALWAYS PUT IT -- IT
HAS THE EFFECT OF LEAVING MONEY
ON THE TABLE I FEDERAL MONEY ON
THE TABLE AND WHEN YOU CONSIDER
THE NUMBER PROGRAMS -- ALTHOUGH
OUR BUDGET -- IS IS DOING.
MORE INVESTMENT IN IN TRYING TO
BRING PROGRAMS BACK -- TO PRE
RECESSION LEVELS -- BY LEAVING
FEDERAL MONEY ON THE TABLE --
IT'S IT'S IT LIMITS THAT ABILITY
TO DO THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
PROGRAMS AND WE SIT THROUGH
HOURS AND HOURS AND HOURS OF
TESTIMONY FROM REALLY GREAT
ABOUT REALLY GREAT PROGRAMS.
THAT SERVE OUR SENIOR POPULATION
THAT SERVE THE ID D. S. CAN BE
IN THE COMMUNITY AND SO MANY
OTHERS.
THAT HAVE BEEN OPERATING ON ON
RECESSION ERA CUTS -- AT A TIME
WHEN WE ARE LOOKING TO EXPAND
COVERAGE TO MANY PEOPLE WHICH I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT.
WE SEEM TO BE LEAVING THE OTHERS
BEHIND AND I AND I AM I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
AND I HOPE THAT -- WE CAN
AGGRESSIVELY PURSUE THE MCO TAX
RESTORATION I THINK -- WE WE
DEBATED THIS A MOST THE PEOPLE
ON THIS DíAS WERE HERE WHEN WE
ACTUALLY HAD THESE DISCUSSIONS A
FEW YEARS AGO THIS IS A RENEWAL
OF SOMETHING.
THAT WE DEBATED IN THIS IN THIS
HOUSE AND IN THE SENATE.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WE WE
TRY TO RESTORE THAT -- FOR THE
INTEGRITY OF THE SYSTEM -- AND
TO HAVE AND AND TO FIND WAYS TO
IT TO FIND ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS
AS WE GO FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOUNG THE FILE ALLEY -- OR
ON FINANCE ONE COMMENT AT ALL.
MISTER COOPER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF COUPLE
QUESTIONS ON G. G. R. F..
WHAT PROGRAMS BE FUNDED AND AT
WHAT LEVEL SPECIFICALLY THE AG
THIS REPLACEMENT PROGRAM IN THE
DAIRY METHANE PROGRAM?
I'LL REPEAT IT IS SPECIFICALLY
THAT DIESEL REPLACEMENT PROGRAM
IN THE DAIRY METHANE PROGRAM.
I AM TERESA COVER WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN THE
ASSEMBLY PLAN FOR A G. G. R. F. --
THERE IS ZERO DOLLARS.
FOR EXCUSE ME ZERO DOLLARS FOR
MESSING REDUCTION THERE IS --
COULD YOU REPEAT THAT THE OTHER
PROGRAM YOU'RE LOOKING FOR THE
JURY NOTHING PROGRAM.
AND THE ACT IS A REPLACEMENT AG
DIESEL OR PLACEMENT -- I DIESEL
REPLACEMENT IT'S UNCLEAR THERE'S
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE ASSEMBLY PLAN FOR CLIMATE
SMART AGRICULTURE WHICH IS WHERE
THE AGRICULTURAL DIESEL ENGINE
REPLACEMENT UPGRADE PROGRAM
RESIDES BUT IT'S NOT CLEAR HOW
MUCH IS ALLOCATED FOR THAT
SPECIFIC PROGRAM AT THIS TIME.
THE SENATE APPROVED FUNDING FOR
THIRTY FIVE MILLION IN DURING
THAT SAME REDUCTIONS BUT A
SPECIFIED THE FUNDS CAN ONLY BE
USED FOR ALTERNATIVE MANURE
MANAGEMENT.
WHAT IS THE SIMPLEST PLAN?
I WE ARE REFLECTING ZERO DOLLARS
FOR THE METHANE REDUCTION IN THE
ASSEMBLY PLANT.
OKAY -- THE FUNDS AMOUNTS FOR
JERRY METHANE REDUCTION SHOULD
BE SHOULD NOT BE SPECIFIED
CURRENTLY ALL FUNDS ARE
ALLOCATED BY CDFA FOR BOTH
ALTERNATIVE MANEUVER MANAGEMENT
AND JERRY DIED JESTERS.
IS IMPORTANT FOR BOTH SETS OF
PROJECTS TO BE FUNDED TO BE
CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS.
IS ALSO IMPORTANT FOR CDFA TO
MAKE THE DECISION ON THE PREP
PROJECTS THAT SHOULD BE FUNDED.
I CANNOT MEET OUR CLIMATE CHANGE
GOALS TO JUST ALTERNATE MANURE
MANAGEMENT.
WE BOTH JERRY DIED JESTERS AN
ALTERNATE MANEUVER MANAGEMENT
PROJECTS TO MEET THESE GOALS.
SO THE FUNDING THE PLANTS NOT
SPECIFY BUT INSTEAD ALLOCATE THE
FUNDS TO SEE THE FAA THE BEST
PROJECTS CAN BE SIX A CHOSEN.
TRULY WHAT ACTIVITIES REDUCTION
GOALS READ ALLOCATE A HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO HER THREE FIVE
MILLION FRAG THESE REPLACEMENT
IN NINE NINE BILLION FOR DAIRY
METHANE REDUCTIONS.
THANK YOU.
EXCUSE MISTER CORPORATE
CHRISTIAN GRIFFITH ASSEMBLY
BUDGET JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
THE WAY THE ASSEMBLY PLANT WORK
WE DIDN'T HAVE.
SPECIFIC SET ASIDE WITH THE
SENATE AND THE MYSTERY SHOULD WE
HAD MORE KIND OF BROADER
CATEGORIES WITH FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR SMART
AGRICULTURE -- WE DIDN'T SPECIFY
HOW THAT WOULD BE USED THE OTHER
THING IS THAT THE ASSEMBLY PLANT
HAD A LARGER AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR
LOW CARBON TRANSPORTATION WHICH
HAD.
WHICH ENVISIONED MONEY -- FOR
THE H. P. PROGRAM WHICH IS FOR
HEAVY AND DAD MEDIAN VEHICLES
AND SOME OF THOSE VEHICLES ARE
AG SO INSTEAD OF HAVING
NECESSARILY AT A SPECIFIC
PROGRAM FOR AG IT'S MORE OF A
GENERAL PROGRAM WHICH COVERS AND
PARADE OF DIFFERENT KINDS OF
VEHICLES FROM PORT VEHICLES.
TO TRUCKS AND TRYING TO MAKE IT
MORE GENERAL SUPPOSED TO
SPECIFIC TO AN INDUSTRY SO THAT
WAS SORT OF PART OF THE GENERAL
APPROACH TO GO TO CONFERENCE
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE WERE GONNA
HAVE TO HAVE MORE CONVERSATION
SO THAT YOUR YOUR POINTS ARE
WELL TAKEN.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MS JONES.
INSIDE THE NO WERE.
WOULD PROBABLY MOVING TOWARD THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE I OBVIOUSLY
I WANT TO CONGRATULATE A DEVICE
CHEERFUL TEAM HOPE FOR
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE CHAD MAYES --
KEVIN MCCARTY.
A JAIL WINNER OF THE INDUCTOR
SHIRLEY WEBER. FIVE MY FAVORITE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS.
AT LEAST THIS WEEK.
AS WE MOVE TOWARD CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE -- THERE'S ALWAYS THIS.
THIS DICHOTOMY BETWEEN THE
SENATE BUDGET IN OURS AND ONE OF
MY ONE TO POINT OUT IS IS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE ADOPT THE
SENATE PACKAGE.
ON ACCESS TO JUSTICE IN THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE AND MOVING
TOWARD THAT AND REALLY IS ABOUT
RESTORING THE STATE ALLOCATION.
LIMITS -- IS ABOUT NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS THAT THE COURTS
WILL BENEFIT FROM -- IF YOU KNOW
THAT THAT THE SOUTH FUNCTIONS AS
A COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT.
NOW AGAINST COURTS WHICH IS
MANAGEMENT AND UNIONS -- A
PREDICTABLE FUNDING SOURCE TO
COLLECTED BILLION BARGAIN IT
REVISED FISCAL STABILITY AND
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTIES AS A LOT
OF MEMBERS HAVE -- EXPELS TO
RIGHT NOW AND IT GIVES THE
COURTS EACH DEBILITATED JUST
THERE -- THE ABILITY TO PAY FOR
THE NORMAL COST OF DOING
BUSINESS INCREASES -- WANTED
THINGS I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
FOR EXAMPLE THE COURT REPORTERS.
I'VE ONLY HAD ONE INCREASE IN
SALARIES OUT AND ALMOST A
CENTURY WITH THE LAST ONE BEING
IN -- NINETEEN NINETY EVEN WITH
THIS -- ONLY PROVIDE ABOUT A
TWENTY SEVEN CENT.
INCREASE IN THEIR SALARIES AND
SO FOR REALLY.
SERIOUS ABOUT RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE IN AND OUR COURTS
INADEQUATELY FUNDING THEM THIS
IS ONE WAY TO DO THIS AND SO I'M
I'M RECOMMENDING THAT WE
SERIOUSLY THINK ABOUT ADOPTING
THE SENATE ACTION -- I WILL I
LABOR IN THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
LEADERSHIP TO MAKES.
A SERIOUS PUSH AS WE MOVE TOWARD
GETTING THE ADMINISTRATION. TO
LOOK SERIOUSLY AT OUR BUDGET AND
COMING CLOSER TO TO WHAT WHAT
WE'RE DOING -- ARE SELLING AT
THANK -- BECAUSE I'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS.
I'M NOT ONLY WITH WITH DOCTOR
WEBER BRIEF CONVERSATION I ONE
ONE THANK CHAIR MISTER CHANG FOR
FOR MEETING WITH ME LAST NIGHT
ALL DAY LONG AND IN.
DOING BILLS AND AND MEET WITH ME
IN THE EVENING TO GO OVER THIS
SUBJECT -- I WANT TO THANK THEM
FOR THAT AND THEN THE SPEAKER
FOR PUTTING ME TOGETHER WITH HIS
BUDGET.
PUBLIC SAFETY ON INDIVIDUALS TO
SERIOUSLY LOOK AT THIS PACKAGE
OF NINETY MILLION DOLLARS AND SO
THAT WE CAN COME TOGETHER AND
WORK TOGETHER WITH THE SENATE --
TO MOVE THIS BOARD -- SO
HOPEFULLY YOU MAY HAVE SOME
IDEAS OF HOW WE CAN GET.
GET THEIR SPECIAL AGO --
DEPARTMENT FINANCES LOOK AT ME
KIND OF FUNNY RIGHT NOW BUT
SOULFUL WE CAN.
WE CAN DO WE CAN MAKE READ IT
WOULD THEY ALL LOOK AT ME FUNNY
SO IT DOESN'T MATTER -- BUT
HOPEFULLY WE CAN TAKE THIS
SERIOUSLY AND AND EIGHT AND FROM
THE EARLY DISCUSSIONS I'VE HAD --
EVERYONE WANTS TO SEE EACH YEAR
TO FIND A WAY THAT WE CAN MOVE
THIS.
FOR THAT WOULD GET YOU GOT THAT
BLANK LOOK SO OKAY.
NOT NOTHING IN COMMON WE'RE
GONNA GO TO MISTER FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- ONE OF
THINGS I WELL ONE COMMON ON
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY PLANT
IGNORE JING THE MCO TAXES DOCTOR
WOULD IS.
HAS SAID IT THE ESSENTIAL
COMPONENT I KNOW THAT IT'S BEEN
MENTIONED IN HEARINGS THE
COMPLEXITY.
BUT THE DEVASTATION IT'LL KERR
IF IT IS REMOVED -- THAT'S
LEAVING ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS ON THE TABLE AND IT
NEEDS TO BE A THOUGHTFUL PROCESS
GOING FORWARD -- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ALSO IN IS.
KIND OF THE OIL FROM THE ROOM
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE IDEA DE
COMMUNITY IS.
IS THE THE RATE PLAN THAT CAME
OUT IN THE END OF MARCH.
STE STATING THAT IT'S ABOUT ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
SHORT IN FUNDING -- THE ID
POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA WITH
THE SINCE IS CONTINUING TO RISE
DRAMATICALLY WITH OUR OUR
POPULATION BY DD FOLKS -- I DO
APPRECIATE OUR CHAIRS OF SUB ONE
AND OR OR ARE BUDGET SHARE GREG
KNOWLEDGE IN.
AND STANDING UP FOR THE
POPULATION.
GOING FORWARD.
HOME WHAT I WANT TO KNOW IS.
ESSENTIALLY.
IS BASICALLY WHAT KIND OF
BLUEPRINT IT WILL BE BUILT. TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE DESPERATE NEED
FOR FUNDING.
THROUGH THE RATE PLAN WHICH IS.
THREE YEAR STUDY.
WE PAID A LOT OF MONEY.
FOR THE NOW SAYS YES.
WHICH WE ALREADY KNEW YOU DO
HAVE A DESPERATE NEED TO FUND.
THIS UNDERSERVED POPULATION.
WHAT WILL WE EXPECT TO SEE
COMING FORWARD?
IN THE UPCOMING YEAR BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT TO COME IN NEXT YEAR
AND SAY.
WELL LET'S START RIGHT NOW.
WE KNOW IT'S HERE WHAT IS THE
PLAN TO BACK FILL THIS ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR KNEE.
TURN OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE -- TO
GOING TO SOME DETAILS OF THE
FIRST IS THAT THE GOVERNOR'S NAY
REVISION -- IN RESPONSE TO THE
RATE STUDY INCLUDES A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN
THE BUDGET YEAR AND AND TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
YEAR AFTER THAT SO WE'RE SEEING
THIS.
AS A PHASED IN PROCESS YOU KNOW
WE FIGURE WITH A SYSTEM THIS
COMPLICATED AND SERVING THIS
MANY PEOPLE WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DO THINGS IN THE RIGHT
WAY.
AND SPECIFICALLY THIS INCREASE
IN THE BUDGET YEAR IS FOCUSED ON
A NUMBER OF CORE PRIORITIES
MAKING SURE THAT WE STABILIZE
THE RESIDENTIAL POPULATION.
MAKING SURE THAT WE ENSURE
SAFETY OF THE PEOPLE
PARTICIPATING IN THE SYSTEM AND
MAKING SURE WE ADDRESS
DISPARITIES IN RATES BETWEEN
VENDORS AND CENTERS ACROSS THE
SYSTEM -- AND AND AS MENTIONED
IN THE MULTI YEAR FORECAST THAT
RATE RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR
REFORMS IN THE SYSTEM AS IN MANY
OF OTHER OTHER HEALTHCARE
SYSTEMS.
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT
THERE'S SOME STRUCTURAL PRESSURE
ON THE GENERAL FUND IN OUR MAY
REVISION COMPARED TO WHAT WE SAW
IN JANUARY -- AND THAT'S THE
REASON THAT THESE RATE INCREASES
OUR SON SIDE.
IN THE NAY REVISION -- PURSUANT
TO THOSE PRESSURES BUT THE
BROADEST POINT I WANT TO MAKE IS
WE SEE THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
HAS TO BE ADDRESSED OVER SEVERAL
YEARS WE'RE COMMITTED TO THOSE
REFORM EFFORTS AND WE WANT TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION WITH
YOU ON HOW TO DO THAT.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT BUT NOT
RECOGNIZING AND AGAIN THE
SUNSETS I CAN SEE.
THE INTENT BUT THE POPULATION
CONTINUES TO GROW AND ABOUT 10%.
A YEAR.
AND SO WE HAVE THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS IN
THE SYSTEM NOW.
EACH YEAR THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
MORE [inaudible]
OKAY SO.
NOT ACKNOWLEDGING THAT WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE NOW WE'RE
FUNDING LESS EVERY YEAR IF WE
DON'T EVEN STAY TO THE THE 10%
MORE POPULATION.
INCREASES.
A ONE OF THE THINGS ALSO.
WE'RE NOT ACKNOWLEDGING IS A THE
THE SERVICE COORDINATOR OF
POPULATION IS ABSOLUTELY.
CRIMINAL HOW A HUNDRED I DE.
INDIVIDUALS ARE SERVICE BY ONE
SERVICE COORDINATOR IN SOME
REGIONAL CENTERS.
THE OTHER IS THE LACK OF
PROVIDERS FOR THE POPULATION THE
WAITING LIST THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE TO WAIT
SOMETIMES ONE TO TWO YEARS TO
EVEN GET A DIRECT SERVICE
PROVIDER.
IF AT ALL.
SO I WOULD LOVE TO SEE AN EFFORT.
TO CREATE A CAREER PATH.
NUMBER ONE OR SOME KIND OF
CERTIFICATE LEVEL.
IT WAS MAKE MORE THAN.
LIVING ARE MORE THAN MINIMUM
WAGE.
AND INCENTIVIZE BECAUSE THERE'S
NO REASON FOR PROVIDERS EVEN
THINK THAT THEY WANT TO HELP
THIS POPULATION IT'S OUR SUNSETS.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
INCENTIVIZE PROVIDERS TO COME IN
THERE IS A HUGE DESPERATE NEED
FOR PROVIDERS WE HAVE ENOUGH
PROFESSIONALS FOR ASSESSMENT.
WE DO REAL WELL AT THAT.
BUT WE DO NOT GET THE PEOPLE ON
THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND THERE
ACTUALLY PROVIDING THE SERVICE.
FOR THE WELL BEING OF THIS
POPULATION I REALLY WOULD STRESS
SO WE WORK TOGETHER. TO LOOK FOR
AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT GOES FORWARD THAT'S BEEN
IGNORED FOR A LONG TIME.
AND WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
SERVICE.
THESE PEOPLE THE OF THE CARE
THAT THEY DESERVE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THIS MESSAGE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WANTED --
TO AGREEING WITH THE BUDGET VICE
CHAIR [inaudible]
THAT -- THERE ARE.
A LOT OF GREAT -- TO STARTING
WITH THE POSITIVES OF THE BILL A
MAN IT IT'S IT'S FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE IT'S IS DEVOTING ITS
IT'S HEARING THE CONCERNS RAISED
BY A SCHOOL DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE -- IN TERMS OF THE TWO
BIG BIGGEST COST PRESSURES
FACING SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
ARE PENSION COSTS IN A SPECIAL
EDUCATION COSTS.
ARM.
I WANT TO THANK THE THE GOVERNOR
FOR PROPOSING.
THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS -- AND
THE ONE TIME PAYMENTS.
TO HELP SCHOOL DISTRICTS -- MEET
THEIR CASTERS -- LIABILITIES --
BUT I I THINK THAT THAT
HIGHLIGHTS.
YOU KNOW THAT WE NEED.
TO WE NEED TO HAVE --
ACKNOWLEDGE THE THE ELEPHANT IN
THE ROOM -- THAT THAT THE
PENSION COSTS AND AND THE YOU
KNOW HOW THOSE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
YOU KNOW -- ARE.
DOLLARS THAT -- THAT MAY NOT
ADDRESS MANY OF THE ISSUES THAT
WE'RE SEEING BEING RAISED IN THE
TEACHER STRIKES FROM LOS ANGELES
TO OAKLAND TO SACRAMENTO -- AND
AND AND AND SO YOU KNOW I I
THINK WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE IT I KNOW IT'S AN AWKWARD
CONVERSATION FOR FOR MANY OF US --
IN IN IN THE LEGISLATURE BED BUT
WE NEED TO TO ADDRESS -- THIS
ISSUE -- I WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER. TWO FOUR FOUR INCLUDING
THE K. THROUGH TWELVE FUNDING
TARGET -- GOALS.
IN THE ASSEMBLY VERSION OF THE
BUDGET HI I HOPE THAT -- THAT IS
WHO IS SURVIVED THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE BECAUSE YOU KNOW AGAIN --
AND ECHOING GO.
THE THE THE BUDGET VICE CHAIR IS
COMMENTS -- WHERE FORTY FIRST IN
THE NATION AND AND THIS IS THIS
IS -- IN A FOR US THE WORLD'S
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY WE NEED TO
DO BETTER -- AND AND AND FUNDING
OUR NUMBER ONE BUDGET PRIORITY --
K. THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION -- A
PROGRAM THAT AFFECTS ALL
COMMUNITIES -- ALL CHILDREN ALL
FAMILIES THROUGHOUT STATE A
CALIFORNIA.
ARM.
I ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT.
AN ONGOING CONCERN OF MINE WHICH
IS -- OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
A WHILE -- WE ARE INCREASING OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA IT DOESN'T GET AS
CLOSE.
TO WHERE WE WERE IN -- WHERE?
CALIFORNIA USED TO BE ABOUT 70%.
WE WOULD SUPPORT ABOUT 70% OF
THE STATE BUDGET OF A OF THE
UNIVERSE A CALIFORNIA A CORE
FUND -- BUDGET WE'RE NOW DOWN TO
ABOUT 40%.
THAT IS THE REASON WHY TUITION
IS INCREASING THAT IS THE REASON
WHY.
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA'S
HAVING TO ADMIT MORE NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS -- TAKING AWAY
ADMISSION SLOTS FOR CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS.
AND SO -- ME TO ALL OF THESE.
AGAIN AT YOU KNOW EVERY EVERY
EXPENDITURE THAT THE WORKER --
ALLOCATING FOR NEW PROGRAMS --
IS IS OUR DOLLARS BEING TAKEN
AWAY FROM WHAT I BELIEVE SHOULD
BE OUR NUMBER -- ONE PRIVATE
BUDGET PRIORITY -- FOR K.
THROUGH TWELVE AS WELL AS FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION.
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND OR THE
LA -- IN TERMS OF THE THE
PROPOSED THE EXPANSION OF
MEDICARE AL. FOR FOR YOUNG
ADULTS REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS WHAT IT'S THE THE COST
ESTIMATE FOR THIS EXPANSION.
SO ALL TURNED OVER TO A
COLLEAGUE TO GIVE YOU THE EXACT
ESTIMATE FOR THAT BUDGET YEAR
ONE POINT THAT I WANT TO SIZE IS
FOR LOGISTICAL REASONS FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR.
THE EXPANSION BEGINS ON JANUARY
FIRST SO THE COST ESTIMATE FOR
THE BUDGET YEAR IS FOR A SIX
MONTH PERIOD AND THEN THERE WILL
BE AN ANNUALIZED COST.
AFTER THAT
.
DO YOU HAVE ANY.
RYAN MILLER DEPARTMENT FINANCE
SO -- UNDER THE MAY REVISION --
AS MY COLLEAGUE WAS SAYING -- WE
HAVE INCLUDED NINETY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS TOTAL FUNDS --
AND SEVENTY FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND --
THAT'S A PARTIAL YEAR -- COST --
AS ENROLLMENT -- WOULD INCREASE
AND AND AS YOU WOULD REFLECT THE
FULL YEAR COST -- I BELIEVE IT --
WILL INCREASE -- TO AROUND TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TOTAL FUNDS.
ROUGHLY AND AND WE CAN CERTAINLY
FOLLOW UP WITH MORE DETAIL ON
THAT FOR YOU.
AND SO I AM SURE IS A FORCE A
SIX MONTH PERIOD OR YEAR PERIOD.
THAT'S FOR A SIX MONTH PERIOD WE
WE ASSUME -- IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE PROPOSAL NO SOONER THAN
JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY OUR IS SO. TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION FOR A SIX
MONTH PERIOD OH SORRY SORRY THAT
THAT'S THAT'S IN -- A COUPLE
YEARS ONCE WE HAVE FULLY
IMPLEMENTED THE PROPOSAL AND AND
AND SO IN THE BUDGET YEAR WE
INCLUDE NINETY EIGHT MILLION.
TOTAL FUNDS SEVENTY FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION GENERAL FUND IN
THE MAYOR VISION.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER PURCHASED
SEVERAL WOMAN RIVAS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU I'D LIKE TO START BY
ACKNOWLEDGING THE WORK -- BUYER
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR LONG
HOURS TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
WE'RE ALWAYS PREPARED AND OF
COURSE OUR OUR CHAIR VICE CHAIR
AND SUB CHAIRS FOR PUTTING
TOGETHER.
A BUDGET THAT I THINK REALLY
REFLECTS OUR STATE'S VALUES --
YOU KNOW AS WE TALK ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE SIGNIFICANT WORK
DONE BY -- BUDGET SUB FOR
COMMITTEE ON HOMELESSNESS THIS
YEAR.
INCLUDING THE HUNDRED THE SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION OF LOCAL
HOMELESSNESS FUNDING THAT WILL
GO TO OUR CITIES -- WELL THEIR
NUMBER OF AGENCIES AND TASK
FORCES THAT ARE DOING GREAT WORK
I THINK WE SHOULD ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE ROLE OF THE
HOMELESS -- COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL WHICH IS OUR
STATE ENTITY -- THAT WAS CREATED
BY THE THE LEGISLATURE -- IT AND
TASKED WITH PREVENTING AN ENDING
HOMELESSNESS YOU KNOW THIS THIS
COUNCIL OVERSEES IMPLEMENTATION
OF HOUSING FIRST GUIDELINES IT
IDENTIFIES RESOURCES BENEFITS
AND SERVICES -- THAT CAN BE
ACCESS TO PREVENT AND END
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA.
CREATES PARTNERSHIPS -- I THINK
WE REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT HOW WE
CAN INCREASE RESOURCES TO THIS
COUNCIL -- BECAUSE THEY ARE
UNDERSTAFFED -- IN EITHER OF
THIS IS OUR STATE ENTITY.
THAT MANAGES AND AND IS TASKED
WITH -- YOU'LL FIND THE BEST
PRACTICES IN OUR STATE -- TO END
HOMELESSNESS -- SO YOU KNOW THIS
IS A CRISIS BUT I REALLY
APPRECIATE ON THE GOVERNOR'S
WORK ON THIS ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIR THE SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS
AND ALL OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR HARD WORK.
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS I'M
PREPARING 220-001-9220 ASSEMBLY
BUDGET.
I'M VERY THANKFUL. TO SEE THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET PRIORITIZE MANY
CRITICAL ISSUES SUCH AS ACCESS
TO EDUCATION AND HEALTH CARE
RAISING FAMILIES OUT OF THE
POVERTY WORKING TO FOR FURTHER
EXPAND RESOURCES FOR HOMELESS
POPULATION.
WHILE MAINTAINING FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND CONTINUED TO
BUILD RESERVES.
I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO THINK.
THE CHAIRS OF SUBCOMMITTEE ONE
AND TWO FOR PART PRIORITIZING
FUNDING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE BREAKFAST
AFTER THE BELL AND DREAMER
RESOURCE CENTERS.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ONE I WOULD
LIKE TO ALSO THINK -- THE CHAIR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA AN
ACTING CHAIR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES FOR THEIR TIRELESS WORK --
IT IS REALLY A TOUGH PROCESS AND
I CANNOT -- BE MORE PROUD THAN
TO SERVE WITH BOTH OF THEM THEY
ARE DILIGENT AND REALLY CARE
ABOUT THE ISSUES THAT CAME
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE -- AND SOME
OF THOSE ISSUES I THAT I'M
THANKFUL FOR IS -- TO ADOPTING
FUNDING TO EXPAND MEDICAL FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE REGARDLESS OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS INCREASE
WHICH RATES FOR SENIOR PROGRAMS
AND EXPENSE SAFETY NET SUPPORT
FOR THE INTELLECTUAL OR
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
COMMUNITY.
WELL WE HAVE MADE MANY STRIDES
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION I AM
STILL HOPEFUL OVER THE FUTURE
NEGOTIATIONS WE CAN CONTINUE TO
FOR THE RESTORE.
RECESSIONARY CUTS AND IN
PARTICULAR WORK TO INCREASE
RATES FOR SERVICE PROVIDERS FOR
THE INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU AGAIN MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING TO FINALIZE
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL NO PRESSURE
VOID WHERE DEPENDING ON YOU
MISTER TING. TO MAKE OUR PER IS
A PRIORITY FOR THE WHOLE STATE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU KNOW NO PRESSURE AT
ALL.
MR MATHIS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- LIKE
EVERYONE ELSE I WANT TO THANK.
THE SOMEONE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
COLLEAGUES THERE ARE STAFF THERE --
LOT OF HARD WORK A LOT OF HOURS
PUT IN -- WORKING TO GET -- OUR
IT DE COMMUNITY TAKEN CARE OF I
KNOW NOT EVERYTHING THAT WE
WANTED.
GOT THERE I HOPE -- MISTER CHAIR
AS WE GET INTO CONFERENCE WE CAN
LOOK AT PUTTING A LITTLE MORE
TEETH AND GET IN A LITTLE MORE
FUN IN THERE -- BUT I DO HAVE --
A COUPLE OF CONCERNS THAT I'M
OPEN -- THE DEPARTMENT MIGHT BE
ABLE TO ANSWER -- YOU KNOW WE'VE
DONE A LOT TO INCREASE HEALTH
CARE AND HEALTH CARE ACCESS.
AND AS WE GO FORWARD AND DO THIS
MY LARGEST CONCERN IS I I REALLY
HONESTLY DON'T THINK WE PUT
ENOUGH AND ON THE PROVIDER SIDE.
SO ON ONE HAND WE ARE INCREASING
THE FLOCKS THAT'S GOING TO GO
INTO OUR MEDIC HEALTH SYSTEM.
IN VASTLY INCREASING THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING TO GO
ON TO THE SYSTEM.
BUT WE'RE NOT DOING ANOTHER OFF.
NEARLY ENOUGH TO INCREASE
PROVIDERS. FOR THAT SYSTEM.
A I KNOW WE'VE HELPED A LITTLE
BIT WITH HOW MUCH THEY'RE
THEY'RE GONNA GET BACK IN AND
HOW THAT'S GOING TO WORK.
BUT AS FAR AS GETTING MORE
PROVIDERS.
OUT THERE.
A AND I'M TALKING MORE DOCTORS
MORE NURSES IN IN DOING THESE
THINGS WE HAVEN'T.
ON ANYTHING VERY SUBSTANTIVE.
AND I HAVE A FAST CONCERNED THAT
WE'RE GOING TO FLOOD THE MARKET
AND WE ALREADY HAVE ISSUES WHERE.
WHEN FAMILIES GO TO SEE THEIR
PRIMARY CARE?
THEY'RE ALREADY WAITING WEEKS.
AND NOW I HAVE CONCERNS IT'S
GONNA BE MONTHS.
SO SO I HAVE A QUESTION ON THAT --
THEY IN THAT I HAVE -- OTHER
QUESTIONS REGARDING AND IN
HOMELESS SO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
ANSWER THAT ONE AND THEN WE CAN
GO TO THE NEXT.
SO I'LL SPEAK BRIEFLY AND THEN
TURNED OVER TO ADAM DORSEY MY
COLLEAGUE SO THE FIRST POINT I
WANT TO MAKE IS WE RECOGNIZE THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT THERE ARE
MORE DEMANDS ON OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM -- UNDER THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT -- WE ADDED MORE THAN
THREE MILLION PEOPLE TO MEDI CAL
PROGRAMS AND OVER A MILLION
PEOPLE TO COVER CALIFORNIA SO WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE MORE
PEOPLE TAKING PART THE INSURANCE.
MARKET -- I DO BELIEVE THAT IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND NAY
REVISION THERE ARE SOME
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE EVEN IF WE
KNOW THAT WE ALL HAVE MORE TO DO
IN THE YEARS. TO COME -- THE
FIRST IS UNDER PROPOSITION FIFTY
SIX MAKING SURE THAT WE DEVOTE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO INCREASING PROVIDER RATE
SYSTEMATIC CAL TO MAKING SURE
THAT.
MORE PROVIDERS ARE SERVING MEDI
CAL PATIENTS WE WERE DOING A
LITTLE BIT THERE BUT AS AS
YOU'VE HEARD FROM TWO OF MY
COLLEAGUES ALREADY DOCTOR WITH
THE MISTER FRAZIER.
YOU'RE LEAVING A LOT OF THAT MCO
FUNDING.
STILL ON THE TABLE.
THAT WE COULD BE ACCESSING THE
INCREASE PROVIDERS [inaudible]
IN.
THERE'S NOTHING IN HERE THAT'S
GOING TO INCREASE THE NEED TO
GET MORE DOCTORS.
SO I MEAN IT'S GREAT THAT YOU
GUYS RECOGNIZE IT BUT I MEAN ARE
WE GONNA DO SOMETHING TO
INCREASE THE ABILITY.
FOR GRADUATION RATES FOR DOCTORS
AND NURSES YES SO -- THE SECOND
THE THE SEVEN POINT ONE NINETEEN
IS THAT ALSO UNDER PROPOSITION
FIFTY SIX WE'RE DEVOTING
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR LOAN REPAYMENTS FOR THOSE
DOCTORS WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
THOSE DOCTORS THAT WILL SERVE
MEDI CAL ELIGIBLE PATIENTS SO.
WE HAD A LOT OF MONEY THERE IN
JANUARY WE PUT AN EVEN MORE
MONEY IN THE NAY REVISIONS SO
THAT IS A PRIORITY FOR HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING TO
SPEND PROPOSITION.
FIFTY SIX MONEY -- AND THEN ONE
OTHER POINT AND I KNOW ADAM MAY
WANT TO WEIGH IN AS WELL IS
SPECIFICALLY ON MENTAL HEALTH
BECAUSE WE KNOW THERE THERE'S A
SPECIAL WORK FORCE NEED -- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAD FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND THEN IN THE
NAY REVISION WE'RE PROPOSING AN
EXTRA HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
UNDER THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACTIVE FUNDING. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ATTRACT MORE PROVIDERS
TO THE MENTAL HEALTH FIELD SO
THAT IS A SPECIFIC AREA OF FOCUS
WE KNOW IT'S NOT A PROBLEM THAT
WE CAN SOLVE IN ONE YEAR BUT WE
DO BELIEVE THAT THIS BUDGET
REFLECTS AN EMPHASIS ON THAT
PRIORITY.
WELL LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU GUYS ON THAT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD -- MY OTHER QUESTION. TO
YOU IS IN REGARD TO THE
HOMELESSNESS THERE'S A LOT OF
MONEY FOR HOMELESSNESS HOUSING.
AND MONEY GOING BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITIES BUT THERE'S NOT A
LOT OF MONEY REALLY ADDRESSING
THE TRUE PROBLEM WITH
HOMELESSNESS AND THAT'S DOING
THE TRANSITIONAL PROGRAMS. TO
HELP OUR HOMELESS POPULATION
TRANSITION BACK INTO LIVING IN
HOMES.
AND TRANSITION BACK INTO BEING
UP TO GET JOBS AND DO THAT.
SO I REALLY INTERESTED -- INTO
WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S PLAN IS IN
REGARDS TO TRANSITIONING ARE
HOMELESS POPULATION BACK INTO
SOCIETY.
IT'S A TOPIC THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT WITHIN SOMEONE -- BUT
DIDN'T GET ANY TRUE CLEAR
ANSWERS ON WHAT TYPES OF
PROGRAMS THAT THEY'RE LOOKING TO
FIND OR HOW MUCH MONEY WE'RE
GOING TO PUT INTO TRANSITIONING --
IN THAT'S REALLY GOING TO BE THE
PROBLEM BECAUSE WE CAN WE CAN
TAKE SOMEBODY WAS HOMELESS AND
PUT ON A HOME PLATE ALL THE
STUDIES SHOW THAT THE END UP
LIVING IN TENTS.
AND IT ESSENTIALLY DESTROYING
THE APARTMENTS THEY GET PUT INTO
BECAUSE THEY'RE JUST NOT READY
FOR IT YET.
AND SO WE REALLY NEED TO ENSURE
THAT THERE'S FUNDING GOING TO
HELP THEM TRANSITION OVER.
I FOR GOING TO TRULY HELP THAT
POPULATION.
I THINK THAT'S IT PERSPECTIVE
THE ADMINISTRATION REALLY DOES
APPRECIATE AND I JUST WANT TO
MENTION TWO POINTS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION BUT I
THINK ADDRESSES SOME OF THOSE
POINTS.
THE FIRST IS THAT ARE
HOMELESSNESS POPULATION -- I'M
SORRY HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL A
LOT OF THE TENSION CAME TO THE
OVERALL INCREASE TO SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY KNOWING WHICH I KNOW
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY OF ALSO.
EMBRACE THAT FIGURE BUT WE ALSO
MADE SOME CHANGES IN TERMS OF
THE PROGRAM DESIGN ITSELF AND I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT TO IN
PARTICULAR.
FIRST IS THAT WE EXPANDED THE
FLEXIBILITY OF THE FUNDING THAT
WE ARE GIVING -- TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS -- BEFORE THERE
WAS A REAL FOCUS ON SHELTERS AND
NAVIGATION CENTERS AND WE
CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THAT THAT IS
VERY IMPORTANT.
BUT TO YOUR POINT WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE CAN MAKE THAT TRANSITION
IS DIFFERENT FOR EACH PERSON IT
MIGHT BE DIFFERENT IN DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE STATE.
SO WE'RE ACTUALLY ALTHOUGH THE
GOVERNOR DOES WANT TO PROVIDE
STATEWIDE LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE THROUGH HIS RECENTLY
ANNOUNCED TASK FORCE FOR THE
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT LOCAL DECISION MAKERS
HAVE THAT.
FLEXIBILITY AND THEN THE SECOND
THING WE DID IN OUR BUDGET AND
WE RECOGNIZE THIS MIGHT BE AN
ISSUE FOR CONFERENCE.
IS THAT WE ALSO GAVE FUNDING NOT
ONLY TO CITIES AND CONVENIENCE
OF CARE BUT TO COUNTIES AS WELL
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE SERVICES
THAT ARE PROVIDED ON THE LOCAL
LEVEL THAT ARE ESSENTIAL FOR
THAT TRANSITION.
ARE PROVIDED THROUGH COUNTIES
THE SECOND POINT THAT I WANT TO
MAKE IS ON HOLD PERSON CARE
PILOTS AND THESE ARE REALLY
PROGRAMS THAT AFFECT
HOMELESSNESS MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES ACCESS TO SERVICES AND
JOB TRAINING AND EVERYTHING
TOGETHER.
WE HAD A ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AND WE ADDED ANOTHER TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS NAY
REVISION BECAUSE WE THINK YOU
REALLY DO NEED TO ADDRESS THE
WHOLE PERSON TO GET AT THESE
ISSUES THAT YOU'RE SPEAKING
ABOUT.
OKAY AND WITH THAT I KNOW SOME
OF THAT IS GOING A AS YOU SAID --
BREAKING IT DOWN IS SPLIT INTO
WITH THE COUNTIES -- I DO HAVE
CONCERN ON HOW THAT SPLITS
TAKING PLACE BECAUSE IT'S PUT IN
OUR ROLE COUNTIES IN JEOPARDY IN
MAKING THEM COMPETE FOR SOME OF
THOSE FUNDS -- AND I HELD DURING
THE MAY REVISION PROCESS YOU ALL
CAN LOOK AT HOW TO SPLIT THAT --
IN A FAIR WAY AMONGST THEM THAT
WAY THEY DON'T WANT TO COMPETE
FOR THOSE FUNDS -- THE BIG
THIRTEEN AS THEY'RE CALLED DON'T
HAVE TO COMPETE IT THEY GET IT
UP FRONT WHICH HELPS THEM AND
PUT THEM STEPS AHEAD.
BUT OUR ROLE COUNTY IS -- ONLY
GET A PIECE OF THE PIE AND THEN
THEY GOT A FIGHT OVER THE REST.
AND THAT DOESN'T REALLY HELP
THEM OUT IT REALLY HARD FOR THEM
ON THE PLANNING SIDE.
SO WE CAN ADDRESS SOME OF THAT
MISTER CHAIR -- AS WE GET TO
CONFERENCE.
PLAY DO APPRECIATE THE THE
GOVERNOR LOOKING AT THE
TRANSITIONAL PIECE -- IT AND
I'VE GOT ONE MORE DAY SHIFT
GEARS ON YOU GUYS -- THE SWITCH
BACK OVER THE AG SIDE -- THAT
MISTER COOPER -- TOUCHED ON I
HAVE GREAT CONCERNS WITH THE
ZERO DOLLARS ADVOCATE YOU DID --
ON THE DERRY METHANE SIDE -- I
REPRESENT THE DAIRY CAPITAL OF
THE WORLD.
AND I'VE SEEN THESE PROJECTS
WORK VERY VERY WELL AND MOVE
FORWARD TO HELPING US REACH.
OUR CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS.
BUT IT'S BEEN A VERY SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM.
AND AND GETTING IT ISN'T GOING
TO HELP US GET THERE.
AND AS WE ALL HEAR ON THE NEWS
OVER AND OVER AND OVER.
NOT TO JOKE WITH THIS IDEA THAT
CALIFORNIA'S ARE CAUSING GLOBAL
WARMING -- THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY THE WAY IT WORKS IN
WE ACTUALLY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
CAPTURE THAT METHANE.
IN USE IT IS NATURAL NATURAL GAS --
WHICH IS ACTUALLY MORE
BENEFICIAL OVER ALL AS RENEWABLE
FUELS SO I'D LIKE TO SEE THAT IT
JUST DID AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN
THE MAY REVISE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- WILL BE GOING TO
ARMS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE'VE
HEARD SOME OF THE GOOD IN SOME
OF THE BAD WILL TELL YOU ONE OF
THE BEST THINGS.
IS THE SUPPORT STAFF.
AND I DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE ALL
OF THE REPUBLICAN CONSULTANTS
AND THE HILLARY.
WHO HELPED TREMENDOUSLY ON THAT
SIDE AND YES -- THAT WAS ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS WE HAD DESK IS
WHERE IS THE BUT I ALSO.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE HARD HARD WORK OF NICOLE
VASCO'S AND HUMAN SERVICES.
AND ANDREA MARGOLIS IN HEALTH.
ARE HELPING US THROUGH THE TO
HELPING ME THROUGH THE
TRANSITION AND SUB ONE WAS
EXTREMELY EXTREMELY IMPORTANT --
AS AS THE ACTING CHAIR OF SUB.
ONE AND IN MY OFFICE I WANT TO
THANK AMHERST SHEET FOR ALL THE
WORK THAT HE PUT IN MAKING SURE
THAT EVERYTHING WAS BROUGHT TO
SOMEONE.
AND MAKE SURE THAT THE REST OF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS WERE UP TO
DATE -- I KNOW LA -- AND
DEPARTMENT FINANCE OF ALREADY
BEEN THINK SO I THINK YOU.
YOUR SYSTEMS WAS INVALUABLE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER STILL
[inaudible]
THE BUDGET.
I GUESS I GET.
GET TO THE POINT ANY OTHER ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS BEFORE WE LEAVE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER STONE VERY
APPROPRIATE.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION AND WE
HAVE A SECOND 'M SECRETARY
COULD YOU CALL THE ROLL.
TING.
TING I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NOT VOTING ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA HI BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BRO.
BRO NOT VOTING CHIU COOPER
[inaudible]
UBER ICEFALL.
FONG NO FRAZIER.
FRAZIER II GALLAGHER.
GARCIA [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
LACKEY NO LIMOS.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
HI MELENDEZ MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE MURATSUCHI.
IN THIS AREA [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE PATTERSON RAMOS HI
RAMOS AYE RADIUS. FOR YES I'D
RIVAS.
RIVAS AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE
STONE.
STONE I AND WEBER.
WEBER AYE WICKS [inaudible]
WOOD [inaudible]
WOOD HI.
THERE SEEMS TO SEE I ICE --
EIGHTEEN TO TO NOSE AND THREE
NOT VOTING.
THANK YOU WERE GOING TO HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN ON THIS AREA.
THANK YOU.
THE WHOLE THE ROLE TO FOR ANY
ABSENT MEMBERS TO AT ALL
.
WELL WITH THE YEAH [inaudible]
YES YES
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER
YEAH